two
what is up everybody this is your top
legal and now analyst uh ethan klein
here
you know i've i've got my law degree
from the most harvard law
very prestigious training
here uh to report exclusively
on the johnny depp
uh versus amber heard trial it's live
right now
it's human fecal matter
[Music]
okay
i'm feeling it
today's a social experiment to see how
high we can get our views from just
talking about johnny depp let's just be
totally honest okay we were talking
about it yesterday we only have 40
minutes to milk this thing and if you're
really
not into the whole i love our you guys
look at our title final verdict totally
click bait guys i'm just trying to get
i'm just trying to get them you know
what i mean
you got uh so so we're just gonna watch
this as a social experiment
um because every all the views of people
streaming this are like nuts hundreds of
thousands uh one of them had like a
million where's that link curry quick
bro
where's that link dude
there's that one that emily recommended
where they don't claim no not that one
yeah yeah yeah i know i'm wrong oh my
god you guys
yeah so we're gonna talk em i even
talked to emily i was like which one
don't they uh
which is the one they don't claim and
she gave me a good one
so
apparently you can't even claim that
that video because based on what emily
said it's unclaimable you can't own that
[ __ ]
but uh here it is is this the one she
said
dude 600 000 people watching
is this the one that she said it says
law and crime i don't think that's the
one she said
let me verify real quick
it is wednesday it is wednesday
so basically um
if you're not interested in this content
i think i'm gonna make it fun i mean
come on guys you know you know we always
have a good time here but we're gonna we
have a lot of other great stuff lined up
after this jimmy lee's in the house
hold it that's not the one
yeah
um
so
what is up it is wednesday my dudes it
is wednesday
yeah it is actually literally wednesday
all right guys let's get this open this
is the one sky news this is this is the
one
yeah man their thumbnail is weird as
hell did you see their thumbnail
look at them no use wait hold on
look at that what what what the hell
look at that
this is must-see tv my dude
you know all right who's this plane
about it hurting or splitting open and
bleeding do you recall any of that
okay here we go
oh thank you to taylor brands expressvpn
and honey for sponsoring this episode
2015. you don't recall seeing any
injuries you can turn up a little bit
damn split lip on amber heard correct
correct
do you recall having any specific
conversation you make it louder
with the hairstylist
that was doing this herd's hair on
december 16th we got a hairstylist 2015
as it related to the abuse that ms heard
was subscribing for you
yeah
yes we have we talked a bit about it yes
what what do you recall about that
conversation
i mean you know i think everybody was a
little like
oh [ __ ] okay um
i think everybody was a little surprised
everybody was a little like not knowing
how to
move forward with it i mean
but we talked as i said when amber was
in the chat yeah
she was behind her and i wasn't there
glasses she's wearing
this you like those yeah showing me the
whole day but just to confirm you don't
know how that chunk of hair was missing
from miss herd's head you don't know
what caused that chunk of water chunk of
hair correct holy crap i don't know it
correct
you don't have any personal knowledge i
should say is she accusing johnny of
pulling a chunk of hero to be missing
from her head well i never i mean i i
did not witness it you sure this is the
one she said amy yeah she said initially
she used the other one the first one i
sent but then she's been using skype
bring up deck 9. you saw the dm i think
if you've testified previously
um that you see
watching the video clip you guys we're
at 25 000 uh watchers at the moment
he's gonna watch that
i know that face so well i've done it so
many times right i can tell where the
bruises are and i can tell where the
swollen lip is correct
we're at thirty thousand
okay thirty thousand
so
please
just keep the update to come in love
this is photography oh wait
chat if they have any questions maybe we
could clarify since we're legal experts
yeah if you guys have any weird tomatoes
in chat it's not about you guys don't
you understand don't be selfish guys
here maybe maybe i'll turn it down
i can't see my makeup so i see the
disclaimer a little bit then
so yeah this is
amber heard's makeup artist okay
some background information there so is
she testifying
for amber or for johnny johnny yes i
believe this is amber herd's witness i'm
not sure though okay
it's like yeah 50 50 yes okay
we do know if it's not for amber then
it's definitely for johnny
we know that right right
by the way we are pro this is a pro
johnny broadcast i just want to make
that clear up front
very much this is a pro johnny uh was
outside the court yesterday actually uh
to greet him when he came out
of the court with a sign that says we
love
you johnny so i am
correct just for everyone for tuning in
uh some people are asking why we don't
have costumes uh we are pro johnny but
in the event that they play some crazy
[ __ ] live
johnny doing some crazy [ __ ] and ethan
is dressed as jack sparrow sitting there
we thought it may be problematic i was
gonna do a whole jack sparrow get up but
i believe
i thought you know my fear was that
people the gen johnny johnny yes
stands tuning in might be turned off by
that
and the goal ultimately
is to get the views as high as possible
so
we are at 26 000. go ahead with the bell
please
[Music]
now
would you be so kind to explain why this
was why the timestamp is february of
2021 right there
and i
oh did they film this previously and
they're just hearing it
but it's still new testimony right
yeah i don't know yeah it's it's new
testimony bro
all right you know i gotta say i think
we're the most honest podcast
on the platform
we just keep it 100.
do you recall anything 27 000
when you first encountered her
can you turn it up a little dan gonna
i'm gonna listen now no i don't think
it's actually your audio guy i like her
i like annie i like her i miss her
her webcam straight into the sun do you
recall miss her discussing any abuse oh
yeah that's a no-no stained the night of
her birthday on april 25th chat if
you're ever recording yourself it's
better to put the camera in front of the
window so the light casts on you
just so you guys know we got tips out
here today
this is our thumbnail
thumbnail
thank you johnny
[Music]
there was some problem that's where they
were late coming back to coachella's
[Applause]
i don't recall exactly what she told me
yeah but there was some problem the
night before yes
but you don't remember seeing any
injuries on this herd
after 28 000 her birthday dinner in
april of 2016. correct
can i get the ding please do you recall
seeing any injuries on this herd's face
at that dinner on may 24th 2016. now
who's interrogating is that johnny
papa's do you recall miss heard it
sounds like it sounds like may 24th
2016.
so this is what a legal expert will call
a cross examination is
as she was
extra and i'll tell you why i remember
this clearly because she was very
distraught
and she was very
um
confused if she should smile enough for
divorce
and she
was really sad and upset
and angry
and all of it and i remember that
because that night
i actually physically took her phone
so she should not
so that it just keep rolling in here
guys we're almost at 29. if johnny tried
to reach
the next day so i remember physically
having her phone
and when i dropped when i dropped them
back at the penthouse she said keep my
phone
so if you contact me
i won't know i won't get it and i will
find one
twitter i went home in my house with her
phone
and
that's why i remember that's what i
stick in my mouth and then the next
morning and you can see those texts she
said i need my phone
and then i had to drive to the penthouse
and give her her phone back and at the
time that day
i'm assuming she fought for divorce and
that day the whole service started
your mom commented on my instagram post
oh really yeah she said you did good but
don't fight again oh yeah i saw that
help me calm down
i think you testified earlier
that amber's practice was to wear
concealer
foundation moisturizer uh please
no do you have any recollection check in
on my mom
i'm thinking oh my goodness
what's going on
hey mom
i'm live just so you know i was just
checking in i just wanted to say hi
you know what i'm doing right now what's
that
i'm playing
oh you're playing mahjong
you're winning
hey better go let's go
go donna you better talk some smack on
your opponent you got to get in their
head
how come you called me what's going on
oh i just have some time on my hands
all right that's fair enough well you
you win that okay you win that call me
back if you win okay i will and don't
call me back if you lose because i don't
talk to losers
i'll call you in a little bit okay all
right thank you all right bye
okay
all right
yes we have another video okay if you
could approach for a moment let me just
certainly dan don't i'm not dan stop
it's not funny
we need the johnny depp trial up i'm
doing that
you can play doom i don't care do
whatever you want but we have to watch
the johnny depp i'm not switching
ian don't do that
guys this is the trial of ascension i
mean if you're showing we're at 30 000
go ahead jack yeah
thank you
so the whole point is that people come
in and think we're watching the trial so
if you're showing doom it kind of
undermines the whole
point of this thing okay
what are they doing now
they're uh i believe what they're call
they call it like a conference or
something where they come and have a
private uh conversation with the judge
sidebar sidebar thank you zach
look at zach pre-law
yeah they're having a sidebar at this
moment
discussing some kind of technicality
probably whatever
but this is live the testimony was old
but this is this is live
right love
right this is live yeah yeah yeah yeah
i'm about to take you for a sidebar
oh wow you know what i'm saying
mm-hmm
okay
we can only imagine what they're saying
so i'm kind of um we can only use our
imagination at this point
yeah cameron's wearing a blazer he came
prepared
oh yeah let me see are you in a suit
jacket okay interesting also kind of
like a lawyer by popular demand we set
up a camera yeah that's so nice yay
i want to get more bunnies out here
though
i want to get like uh
this is my legal advice to get
me some stuff bunny animals out here
dude we have the best technology in the
game look at that we got a mic n
and camera for cam who's like sitting on
the opposite side of the office yeah
dude like at least like 15 feet away
cameron is very nice pretty impressive a
lot of people think we didn't all right
your next witness what are we going to
call christie sexton
as well yeah
all right
31 000. okay thank you
now is it too late to point out to you
that the other day when you started
talking about this and the views went up
um the trial had just ended and so those
infusion of views was likely just a lot
of people
finishing watching whatever stream like
emily baker or whatever and then popping
over to our stream and it was probably
just a coincidence well today's an
experiment and we're going to find out
because we're almost at 32 so
we're go we're going to find out i mean
that's what today is all about the chat
said last time it was five o'clock on
the east coast too so people are getting
off work we're gonna find out right now
there's no such thing as the coincidence
we're gonna find that out
okay so who's this
let's watch residency here this one's
from december 2019 okay player and all
my paperwork subsequently it's [ __ ]
two years ago
all right of 2017. why not
i take it from your last answer mr
sexton that australia was the lucky
winner
[Music]
33.
yeah when was it
that she took a class
uh that you would be a number that i
believe it was sometime in two weeks
let's go
i mean 50 would be let's go
okay
um i don't know about exclusive we don't
have any sort of exclusivity can you
guys hear the video it's good
uh last time we worked on a project
together would be aquaman so 2017.
you know yesterday was the really
exciting one with amber yeah but i do
want to watch some highlights from that
because there was some great moments
yeah we got a bunch uh the last time we
worked on a project together when will
you be announcing the verdict
the verdict comes you guys have to stay
tuned because it comes at the very end
of the show
do you have to watch the whole thing
no skipping
yes
i take it from what you just described
that although the frequency varied
um it's fair to say is it not that you
saw
ms heard many many many times
during the period between
2010
and 2017. oh yes
would it be fair to say that you saw
miss heard during this seven year period
um more than a hundred times
easily yes
love who was this i missed the intro
do you think it's funny
the lawyers get to object afterwards so
they get to do edits to it whoa that's
crazy
yeah while in a in a live hearing they
would have to object before the answer
so they went through a whole process
just to get these out
that's nice and really stretching
herself that's right an actor
she which is all bro just re-upped his
membership and said the tick-tock lawyer
could clear amber turd's name totally
that's what i
work
he get
and go over things
a lot
so she was very driven as an actor to uh
someone gave me some details
in
we're
her
at
33 33
33 000 watching
let's go
yes it was either 2011 or 2012. um
if it's
i would say sometime in the middle of
the following year
acting coach
chat knows acting code
at her house
who is she acting coach for uh turd hey
ela i'm alive we're just watching the
johnny depp deposition
okay
what's going on
good i mean we're at 33 000.
which is still in the realm of normal so
we haven't quite busted through the
glass ceiling yet
did you do it grumpy
uh i haven't done a grumpy today
have you okay
[Music]
[Music]
when
[Music]
yeah no we're live we're just watching
the uh acting coach for amber
uh doing a testimony it was recorded in
2019 by the way literally lighting would
go down and
big curtains would be
interesting
became much less talkative as time went
on yeah no it's got my full attention
personally i would feel him in the house
[Music]
all right well um
what do you want for dinner do you want
me to get anything
at different points in time i heard
different things
i don't know sometimes it would just be
him milling around the house sometimes
what are you in the mood for
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
all right
animation just gifted one h3 podcast
membership oh we can do gifting
gifting got turned on
shout out to afris that's our first
gifting sub hold on elo just called back
and then uh yes
i remember yeah what's up
while you're here talking right i didn't
mean to so um yeah
okay thank you for saying that all right
take care all right take care now okay
bye-bye
um
should i call oliver tree that's
something people suggested
with drugs and alcohol okay in the early
parts of their relationship i probably
want to answer it i said that he was so
i don't think so um she was trying to
work
i don't know if he gets up before like
two thirty three o'clock should we touch
that yeah i mean you could try what the
all kinds of gifts are coming through
yo 20 gifted subs mega man wait we gotta
call these people out mega hey oliver
oliver you're live on the show right now
what are you playing stuff like that i
heard william blackjack
[Applause]
[Music]
200 get out of there
no
if you're up 200 walk away now trust me
bro just listen to me you'll be so happy
walk when you're hot
listen to me bro okay
all right so can i stay on the phone and
see if you win then let's see just get
updates
i just walked away from the table what
do you need
nothing i'm live we're watching the
johnny depp trial and i just wanted to
check in
you did not dude
yeah no we're live that's what that's
the first thing i said to you by the way
initially when i would you tell me
you're live now dude i would never have
said about my money on my personal
matters
it's the first thing i said to you when
i called you i said we're live
i didn't hear [ __ ] dude why the [ __ ]
would you do that that's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] to do i would never talk about
my finances online okay well you are
still live just so you
know we maybe just take the livestream
off and you call me back
i can call you when we're not live but i
can't take the livestream off we're
doing the johnny depp trial
why are you watching that dude you're
not supposed to be doing that
i don't know thank you
we have 34 000 views go ahead with the
bell uh people i don't know on youtube
everyone's streaming this [ __ ] and like
they get a ton of views so we're kind of
just experimenting with it
just let the whole thing be that's not
cool for you to be promoting that for
your little show all right
[Applause]
anyway
we could add oliver to the title now
decreasing as it went
um um you guys want to give a shout out
to um
wait we should shout out to all the
gifting members working on anything at
all sure
in one second
[Laughter]
shout out to veronica for gifting five
that's so exciting so exciting veronica
thank you veronica
come like the menorah i don't know why
that works
oh hanukkah veronica veronica hanukkah
yeah yeah i can't believe mega bought
20. it's like dude what a [ __ ]
legendary king dude
how does the gifting work does it i will
call a song
how does it work does it go to i think
it randomly distributes it to
non-members that are currently in the
live sometimes whoa that's so sick
so
some of y'all might be getting
um
just a free sub from one of our gracious
members yeah did we call out all the
gifters michael ramirez gifted five
look at that michael
michael
i have someone said how do i gift the
sub i have no idea
i literally don't know they just added
the feature
35 000.
i have a feeling uh the option will not
be there if you are on an iphone because
they are always slow to roll out oh my
god we're getting so many messages guys
but if you're on desktop you probably
have uh
love you ethan house teddy and bruce
billy gifted five just now billy thank
you so much there was another one this
is
five thank you guys this is so cool
gifted five holy [ __ ] charger what's up
player oh my god canoe mountains
the canoe
oh my goodness johnny shout out johnny
depp
uh
holy [ __ ] this is the real view driver
if you get in here right now someone
just said
shout out
let's go oh guys wait we shout out
they're going so fast allison shot him
out alison juaro
gave five thank you guys this is awesome
macaroni tony just gifted five wow
um somebody asked uh how
one of the uh members out you could
actually get something accomplished what
the hell is going so fast
um
jesus anthony b
there's johnny johnny's on screen
you guys like his bun
swim and sleep
i mean it's nice it's like he's looking
nice he's trying to look you know
professional for courts julia just
gifted
so i figured out how the memberships
work existing channel members click the
money icon next to live chat to purchase
gift memberships on live stream they
distribute based on engagement so if you
interact with the channel more you're
more likely to get a membership oh
interesting yeah no way that's awesome
that's a nice little thing but how does
that work because we have member only
chat on it says example uh loyal members
who are always watching interacting with
your content more likely to receive i
watch high watch time comments left and
stuff yeah does twitch doesn't do that
do they love do you know
yeah i think on twitch it's completely
random that's so awesome so like the
biggest super troopers
get gifts from the from the most
gracious super troopers yeah that's so
freaking cool we're the biggest haters
can you turn it up then i can't hear you
zach is that why you turn it down
because you were talking people are
watching the people are watching the
trial
uh jillian mitchell just gifted one sub
thank you jillian they're not missing
anybody i do appreciate you it's just
moving really fast caretaker personality
this is so cool thank you guys wow this
is a meta by the way we've been thinking
what would be another fun members live
stream because it was so much fun
the creators clash
so i think in the coming weekend i don't
know we can work out when it's best for
everyone as much as i could as a friend
um
so
we should watch happy feet or whatever
the light of the world
tiptoes is even worse than happy feet
tiptoes is honestly so offensive
oh my god you guys are so generous thank
you so much
it's so nice
thank you guys
we gotta do an awesome members stream
yeah
then i don't know when you guys want to
do it like i don't know how soon you
guys
hear this i'm done whenever i i wish i
went to i could go to the last one that
one looked like well you were busy yeah
i was busy playing until she would open
the door santa bain gifted five and then
it would go back wow man syntax i'm kind
of blown away somebody just gave me
money holy [ __ ] yeah syntax
thank you guys so much i'm kind of blown
away this is so generous
i think the chat is going crazy because
there's so many new members now
thanks to all the gifting oh true
witness to some of those you didn't want
her going out without
it actually puts a message yeah i see
like colin sigmund was gifted a
membership by i am johnny yeah yo
that's so that [ __ ]
honestly it's so nice that it gives it
to people who actually watch
i think that's so brilliant
albex gifted five
whoa tai ornates let's give ten dude you
guys are so nice this is insane behavior
change what's the pricing like that like
the equivalent of buying
yeah or maybe it's a deal so they only
allow you five ten or twenty memberships
five is twenty five dollars ten
memberships fifty dollars twenty a
hundred
so it's just five bucks right yeah so
it's the same it's the same price yeah
but you can't do a single one no no
package deal wait i've been seeing some
that say bought one gift membership are
you sure you can't do one i'm not maybe
you can maybe you can do a custom amount
or maybe you can gift a specific person
oh god thank you guys so much it's so
nice to be gifting the other pooper trip
the family you know this is a family
moment because y'all are buying family
members
true
the gifts it's really nice should i keep
reading them out
i mean
yeah yes
john gifted five going out
john
johnny johnny johnny johnny's going out
at night that kind of thing
um
wow wow wow here's another five samantha
jones thank you very much for the five
years
dude that's such a cool feature this is
freaking this is kind of like
dude you two are gonna
you do kind of gonna destroy twitch with
this feature
i love the engagement alone but yeah i
mean it it definitely seems like it's a
better implementation than the gifts of
family family although it took them
eight years to do it family family
family family family
family family family
family family family family stop stop
waiting stop
uh this is such a good stream i mean uh
what's going up uh the uh deposition is
she's always
been fit but she would drop down and get
a little gaunt it's kind of crazy throws
just gifted one h3 podcast membership
there is a way somehow there's a way to
do it one at a time
i love you from chicago hiding my
checking phone so i can listen at work
thank you guys
don't get caught oh my god you guys
thank you so much corey
specifically because i wanted to say
amber hurts body um
her like dating history is pretty
incredible
like don't get me wrong she's she's a
beautiful girl she's gorgeous but like
she looked uh she was skinny elon musk
um
james franco
johnny depp like who else is she so i
know during that she's i mean that's
quite a roster don't you think she was
very pretty impressive
oh wait oliver wants me to call him back
[Music]
on return
oh jesus i told you to walk away man
we're live by the way i'm telling you i
lost everything
i told you i lit it that always happens
they always get you that way bro i told
you to walk away from the table kill me
dude
we did
nothing no
that's all he was saying so what
happened
i put everything on black i saw that
i had literally
200 [ __ ] thousand dollars on [ __ ]
black dude and it literally hit the red
number 22.
oh
black usually works for me man i would
have that's [ __ ] up i'm sorry i don't
know what the [ __ ] to do dude it wasn't
even my money
whose money was some money today
my uncles oh [ __ ]
i'm sure he'll understand i mean you're
a popular artist you could pay him back
no
no he's not gonna [ __ ] understand
this was everything you had
well you [ __ ] you you couldn't you
should have walked away bro this is your
own fault man
who wants me to take their life my
[ __ ] fault you don't understand it
dude this is a [ __ ] this is gonna be
a future 37 000 oh hell yeah listen
oliver i got
if you want to make the money back go
live and stream the johnny depp amber
heard it's insane bro you get so many
views
everyone's super hyped you can make that
200 000 back fast
what are you talking about stream what
the johnny depp trial it's live right
now i don't you don't see that anymore
okay is really now the time to be moral
grandstanding i mean you just [ __ ]
lost 200 000 of your uncle's money but
yeah that is a good point you don't
understand it was my whole family's
money it was my uncle's money who loaned
it to me but that money was coming from
my grandmother's account
whoa no
bro i don't know what to tell every bro
i'm sorry what do you want me to do
about it i mean you can i don't know
dude i'm down bad and i
i have the money on the sale today and
nobody bought tickets
everything's falling apart ethan you got
to help me man
you want me to help you sell some tour
tickets
oh man it would mean the world right now
i'm done
all right where do people buy touring
tickets
oh retreat.com
you're [ __ ] lying bro you're just
trying to sell your tickets yes you are
oh we put the door up today man and it's
just no but no we haven't sold more than
three tickets
and we're down bad dude
you're such a liar bro you're just
trying to sell tickets get the [ __ ] out
i'm watching
i'm not a piggy bank my fans are not a
piggy bank for you dude
that's what you treat them like you have
no respect thirty eight thousand zach
there's gotta be at least one person
who's watching this stream right now who
wants to go who doesn't know about this
everywhere
okay
all right dude whatever olivertree.com
please i said it olivertree.com what the
[ __ ]
forward slash music
you're such a loser bro i don't know
what to tell you
ethan i'm down bad bro and i need your
help i'm doing everything i can i just
plugged it
i need you to can you can you post a
tweet
oh hell no
now you just snap now you're just
[ __ ] with me i'm not posting [ __ ] for
you complete ethan ethan listen to me i
need you to tweet this out please i'll
send you a link right now man
i'm missing an emergency man it's a
family emergency bro there's no [ __ ]
chance of me tweeting out your twitter
link tell them
because i know your podcast fell off
nobody's watching it 38 000. some real
kind of support 38 000 used to get in
the half millions live stream no i
didn't what happened you used to be a
star
okay if you can name then if you can
give me the name of my new
son
my youngest son then i'll think about it
yeah
what exactly michael yeah it's not
michael dude there's no tweet for you
bro please i need this and dude i think
this is in the best interest of you and
gila and michael because i think that
this is not michael
his name's not michael
what's his name i'm not telling you bro
if you were a [ __ ] real fan you would
know it
i i'm not i'm i'm his godfather of
course i know his name's michael you're
not his godfather
yes you said theodore and michael both
you promised no
all right listen i'm so sorry you lost a
bunch of money
uh it was my family's money it wasn't
even mine okay this i i i
all
[Music]
all right what do you want me to tweet
i need you to treat everybody who's a
real super trooper please go buy tickets
and see oliver tree
[Music]
get some help okay call the gambling
there's a gambling
uh there's people that can help you with
that okay all right
i'm not tweeting that
can we tweet it from the podcast again
no no we're not tweeting that okay do
not tweet that you guys do understand me
nobody tweet that [ __ ] i attended the
party
this guy's such a [ __ ] loser
you know why i talked to him still
um
you say you
described
the party you attended who was there
the party was happening in one of the
penthouses the one that they didn't live
in it's where they did most of their art
and we did most of our coaching all
right um and i don't remember the number
of that one
uh
and there were several friends of
members there
and we spent the first couple hours
waiting for johnny
um
so basically what's going on here um
just let's not stop waiting for him
let's just start this is the uh she's
the acting coach
[Music]
thank you for all the gifted sub today's
guys that was just awesome man that was
so much fun
that was just incredible
brand new
[Music]
[Music]
from johnny johnny and amber clearly so
we did tweet it out guys if you can send
me the link down i'll tweet it out in a
second
she would try to kind of touch her and
she would shy the guy's convinced me
behind the scenes too
since he's down so bad trying to change
the tone of the party because it had
really gotten very somber at that point
we're gonna tweet it out from from the
podcast chat so one one second around
the table everyone shared their stories
and
um when we got to johnny i just tweeted
[Music]
amber's ass on his couch
were his words so guys
we were gracious enough
[Applause]
edit tweet so he said olive tree oh
olive tree the bible app well
this is good too helps millions of
people read and study the bible is there
a tour tab maybe somewhere at the i was
yeah as i said amber was you can buy
bibles a pillar new testament with
commentary
all right well i'm not we can't edit the
tweets so
right this is taking up too much time
olivetree.com
uh
amber's 30th birthday party i think you
testified
like can we talk about like the
political and economic state of the
world right now i'm sorry this isn't
good enough for jayden what's your
favorite we talk about what's going on
with the environment can we talk about
other things
well
okay what do you want to talk about all
uh jaden locked arms with him that's his
name right
yes
he's probably streaming so
yeah he might not answer
uh i just want to point out the views
did dip a little bit no they didn't yeah
did they
just a couple hundred but
okay
okay so this is interesting we gotta
feel where the roof's at with this few
days later i see it going up dan i think
you're talking some bowls
i'm literally looking at it's going up
i'm looking at it i just went down again
no way i'm watching it i am also
watching it
this is interesting this is really
interesting look at the look at the line
graph here well i'm just looking at the
live parts
it's at it's well that might be a little
delayed i'm looking at the background it
just went down five there we go
i went over it was sometime in august
okay this is a problem guys to have wine
and catch up because like i said react
harder maybe it's time to
do you want me to react harder
let's just actually pretend like we're
watching this and see if it goes up okay
all
right
let's see what happens yes
did mr mention any of the allegations
that mr jeff is against her
in relation to this case exactly
only to say it's not appropriate to talk
to the attorneys about it yeah we're
going well it's going up
yeah okay good keep going
when you say only to talk to the
attorneys about it
specifically didn't tell you
like she said would you be willing to
sit down and talk to my attorneys about
everything that you witnessed
um
[Music]
and then afterwards i
after i kind of talked about it all it
felt really intense to me and i felt
incredibly guilty
during one of these two times that you
met was returned in august of this year
that mr told you for the first time that
mr jeff had
allegedly raped her with a bottle you
know
like super election some people think
something shocking happened
was it the first meeting that you had
in august this year that she mentioned
that
no about it
39 going back up dan i had come to see
her and had a while you see that and
catch up and then i after i had talked
to the agent not in the back end yet but
it may
take a second to refresh
i do see that okay yeah 38 39 39 39 hit
it down
there you go
should be everything
that's when it came out
and just to confirm
before your definition
your first deposition in the case in
august of 2019
uh
yes
it was after i had talked to the
attorneys
it dropped back down to 38 yeah
maybe i'm not reacting hard enough yeah
i think you know what
no see what you're doing the problem i i
see the problem
right now you are just intently watching
maybe even intensely watching you need a
lot more like
oh
whoa okay okay really oh it's back up to
39. okay what you just said yeah yeah
yeah yeah i got you okay throw in some
uh what the fricks okay all right mr
jeff had allegedly penetrated her with a
bottle
in australia correct
yeah she had told me about the assaults
with the bottle being hit with the
bottle and the burping glass and
everything
um that is a lot yeah yeah that is
serious she had told me about all that
many times before
and then this time she started crying
and sobbing kudari kitten with the 10
gift subs
memberships
thank you thank you so much to jerry all
right back to this horrific incident
that we're hearing about did she know
that you were going to be deposed by her
attorney
uh no because they were all in the other
room
and they didn't even tell me that they
like they were like we may have you for
a deposition
and that's when i had said to them if
you're gonna do that i would appreciate
it if you did it before i left the
states
um and they said we may or may not need
you and it was a couple days later
that they then sent me the contact and
said we are going to subpoena you okay
okay interesting
can you tell me how many times you spent
maybe a significant amount of time with
mr nick i would say probably around like
10 or 20 times
10 or 20 times
[Music]
apparently he's mid interview right now
so people are saying this is actually
very serious exactly not many
ashley
or rolling a joint or having wine
um it always seemed to me that
he's not a social
animal
if you will um and
he would have a drink or smoke in order
to
go talk to people is what it felt like
but um
so most of the time i saw him it was
that
you would agree with me though
that someone getting a drink is
different than someone appearing
correct
his first drink
of the day so my question is a little
bit more specific
on the 10 or 20 times that you saw mr
should i try walking out of frame and
seeing if it goes up
he was very quiet when he was sober and
before he would start drinking he was
very quiet
um
almost a whisper mumble most of the time
and then you would get very loud when he
was inebriated um still hovering right
around 39k
first and telling like cool stories and
stuff
wasn't called olivia and then it would
move into the
yeah
it did go up it does it's going up a lot
here
maybe it'll help if i make it smaller
too
[Laughter]
just make it smaller i'm
per se yeah just put if you could you
put it in the corner
i remember him like yelling and
screaming and the bodyguard coming over
and be like hey boss let's let's take
this to another room
okay
all right perfect
i remember being in the kitchen
of that house
um
and he came down and he 20 from zorro
instead of buying myself a membership
here's 20 for ab specifically great
showing that michigander powers you
don't want to go
a quarter to zach it was late 313 baby
thanks dude it was really dark in there
um
in my memory it's very dark it's going
up guys people just think it's a stream
he's yelling and right that
older guy maybe we should just stop
talking maybe kill our mike
all right boss
i feel like her audio might be a little
distracting too maybe we should just
kill the audio from from there should we
just mute everything just look at her no
no don't mute her oh no just mute armor
don't recall what was happening yeah
kill our mics for a second let's see if
it goes up
or
if it was even at anybody who was just
kind of
down there and drunk and
scooped them up
you anticipated my question
questions which were
who was he yelling at and what was
yelling about so you don't recall is
that correct no i don't
and you said the other instance that you
remember of mr jeff's appearing
initiated and
meaningless as collected penthouses in
downtown l.a is that correct
what were the circumstances
that you remember about that
i remember one time he was mad
that people were in the house because i
had just gotten there i don't even
remember
there had been like two people there or
something i don't remember um
but yeah he was storming up those stairs
to his office bedroom area
um
and then amber and i went to the other
penthouse to work
and in either incident
it felt that peter and at the penthouse
um when you saw mr death and you heard
me breathe and was angry and yelling did
you see him
hit his heart at any point
no i did not see him hit her
did you see him kick at first
i did not see him take her
did you see him throw something after
her
i saw him
coming at her and that's when the
bodyguard stepped in like coming towards
her but i did not like it so throwing
himself at
like but i was not
witness to him throwing objects at her
when you say
he was coming at her are you describing
the incident as feature
sweet sir he came in through that
hallway and we were sitting at it was
kind of like an island there
guys uh right in front of the fridge the
views are going up so came in from there
it was like coming at her and then the
guy the bodyguard whatever we're doing
is working so i'm just going to close my
mic again okay
this is the incident you don't remember
what mr jeff was yelling about or
why yes
but it appeared to you
that mr duff was coming at her yeah
she was shaking and upset
[Music]
it felt like something that had been
going on for a while
and all the time that you've known was
heard and mr jeff
did you ever see mr jeff be violent
towards the curse
i never saw him hit her
heard him use terminology as i said
before
and
as i said come at her
but i never saw him hit her
if i had i would have called the cops to
be honest
you never saw mr death
throw anything after any objects
correct
no the only thing i saw was the
aftermath
like i would see things broken
afterwards
um
and like i said in hicksville i heard
the yelling and then saw the breaking
and saw him apologizing for it but i
with my own two eyes did not see him
physically break the stuff or throw the
stuff
when mr jeff and ms hearn went to
australia did she tell you that
she threw a bottle of vodka at him and
that that's what covered his finger
no no she had told me that he had broken
the bottle and cut himself with the
bottle that he had broken
[Music]
when she told you that he had cut
himself with a bottle he had broken did
she say that he had
taken the bottle and cut off his finger
or just an accident
and then his finger was severed from the
broken bottle
do you understand the distinction yeah
she didn't say that
she didn't indicate that he cut off like
went purposely to cut it
what it seemed to me is that he had
broken the bottle against something and
then
he was
doing things with the bottle like
shaking it around okay guys we're at 40
000
from that um
you can make my screen a little bigger
purposely thank you
something to you in a conversation guys
the less i do the better for years at
this moment
so i remember a specific time when amber
still lived at orange and
amber was out with her girlfriends and i
had come over too early for the party so
it was just johnny
having
and he was smoking cigars
um and
he was talking about
that it was
i said something about he said he had to
get up early to do a test and i was like
oh don't you have any sort of like
concern about that and he's like it's
easy to fake insurance to us that's why
we do what we do
i was talking to him because another
client of mine had had to do an
insurance test and he was like oh you
can fake a piss test you can do this
and he just kind of went over a few
different ways that it's easy to take
insurance tests and made a joke of it
all right ladies and gentlemen we come
to the end of the the day today so have
a good evening and we'll see you
tomorrow at 9 00 a.m
again did not discuss the case with
anybody and don't do the outside
research okay have a good evening
okay
don't leave don't leave don't leave we
have more we we have the highlights from
from yesterday so play them quick before
people realize it ended
up get let's watch the yeah yeah yeah
yeah guys it's not over it just started
this is the amber herd testimony
damn why is the audio so dog [ __ ] do you
have any remote witnesses tomorrow that
you need to access for
do you need a webex you don't need a
webex lane no we don't need webex here
let's watch this one guys it's not over
it's not over okay all right that sounds
good all right everybody knows their
homework right
okay okay
we'll see you in the morning you better
hurry
no okay okay okay
okay we're just gonna fight send me that
link when you find it okay
yeah so this is actually um
amber heard is about to take uh
the seat which is really crazy
this is live
and she's about to take the seat right
now so that's interesting right
okay she's being sworn in
this audio is fantastic thank you you'll
be seated yeah next question
this isn't the audio quality is it
go to page eight okay let's just i'm
gonna ask you oh this is all live at
plankton's exhibit eight eight okay
um this is one don't leave don't leave
don't leave guys this is live it's by
adam waldman is that correct
okay good seen the article yet okay why
don't we go to page eight of this
article
adam waldman duff's lawyer said
afterwards
right now because again sexual violence
the other people streaming no no that's
not why that's not why dan it's been
going up steadily the whole time no it's
true but i'm think i'm predicting like a
spike now that the actual like you know
our fan our crossover fans from emily
baker
stuff
coming over
or defamatory this is a new broadcast i
don't know what you're talking about
what ended okay um can we please go to
plaintiff's exhibit 881b
and if we could go to
page 10
and 11. guys don't leave don't leave
this is a new one
somebody just donated five dollars that
send this to oliver please
okay all right
exhibit plaintiff's exhibit
you're going to need it he's going to
need a lot more than five bucks
very important but nothing her and her
friends said about the events of may 21
2016.
incredible quite simply
a hoax yeah 69 shekels
it's like five bucks like they are yeah
yeah yo big ups big ups
here shout out to you
shout out to the island y'all got to
change to one of the multi-cam streams
the best part is johnny and zoya's
reactions too like this one bs embers
witnesses say this one is multicam that
we're watching now okay fair enough yeah
good call though wait is the one you're
sending multicam and then place the
second call to 9-1-1
but even this didn't have oh apologize
you're fine
okay
[Music]
did you did you send the last point we
do
this is a sponsored episode oh [ __ ] i
have to do some ad reads we're hit we're
way over uh but it just didn't really
feel totally forgot
to interrupt
your contract so wait where is this uh
where did you timestamp
said about the events of may 21 2016
could be considered credible quite
simply this is an ambush a hoax
dude it's way after down
isn't it
guys this is live
uh tom may i please have you put up uh
plaintiff's exhibit eight eight yeah
yeah one yeah right here why don't we go
to page eight yeah this article okay
guys please don't leave all right dan
where'd you go damn left
all right guys
[ __ ] all right don't leave i promise to
god we're gonna we just gotta thank our
sponsors real fast don't [ __ ] leave i
swear to god dude
this is live okay you guys are gonna
miss
leave the leave the number up then i
want to know how many cowards are
leaving during the ad raid
give me one second and again you can you
can leave it like that it's fine it's
gonna leave it like that
you're gonna do the address on screen
yeah uh no let's not do that
but but i can't get you a number counter
if you give me just one second all right
so should i wait for the should i
[ __ ] you wanted the number counter right
well should i just start reading already
i mean then you'd be doing the sponsor
read without the number counter i don't
know if anybody wants to watch that
whoa okay milk ham donated 100
milk ham
milk and
[Music]
yeah and he says you can can you guys
use this to buy olivia some flowers when
she gets oh that's so nice absolutely
not
michelle morris donated a hundred
dollars too well thank you guys that's
100 for the crew but ethan can take five
percent
he wants to do that
you're killing me
all right let me just do these sponsors
we got to do this [ __ ]
maybe we should get to the rest of the
show to be honest
because we got jimmy lee here
we got to get to the jimmy lee
my internet just went out
all right dan let's
okay here we go
all right thank you to taylor brands
did you know that you can register your
business and listen to this podcast at
the same time that's right make your
business official just got a lot easier
thanks to taylor brands yeah you guys
know i run businesses if you're a sole
proprietor you wanna
llc that or incorporate that beach
because you get write-offs baby you can
write it all off
this isn't legal advice and i don't
technically know what i'm talking about
but you can write everything off get a
business card put everything on it and
let god sort it out right dan
again
this is not financial advice or legal
advice or advice of any man
taylor brands can help you form an llc
no paperwork or anything you just answer
some questions and let them do the rest
it's crazy they also give you the tools
your business needs in one place and i
mean everything business logos business
websites domain names merge social media
posts a digital business card and so
much more
you'll be surprised how easy is actually
the real reason you want to llc or
[ __ ] we're dropping fast uh the real
reason you want to llc or
to incorporate is because
it help it prov
protects you from liability you know
somebody if something happens whatever
it is someone sues you
they can't get your personal assets they
can only uh sue the company that's why
you want it so it's a good idea uh and
you know here's the best way to do it
because if you're listening right now
use the
code
uh or the link and you get forty percent
discount just go to taylor
brands dot com slash h3 that's taylor
brands dot com slash h3 for forty
percent up go to taylorbrands.com today
and build the business of your dreams
thank you
next up is expressvpn
using the internet without expressvpn is
like having a first aid kit but not
keeping it stocked up most of the time
you'll probably be fine but what if you
suddenly get into a horrible accident
there's nothing in your first aid kit to
help you stop bleeding
every time you connect to an encrypted
network cafe hotel airport any hacker on
the same network can gain access to your
personal data i'm talking about
passwords finances
etc
and it doesn't take much technical
knowledge to hack someone you know
a smart 12 year old could do it and
that's true theodore's actually he's
taking his first course in hacking right
now you just hacked the uh sesame street
network
devastating stuff your data is valuable
you know hackers can make a thousand
dollars per person selling your info on
the dark web
so why should you use expressvpn
expressvpn they have encrypted tunnels
it sounds sci-fi
creates a
secure encrypted tunnel between your
device and the internet hackers can't
steal your sensitive data it's super
secure if a hacker with a super computer
it would take a hacker with a super
computer over a billion years to get
past expressvpn's encryption it's easy
to use fire it up
uh click one button and you're protected
just fire up the app works on all
devices phones laptops tablets and more
so you can stay secure on the go
i love expressvpn not just for the
safety and security
but for watching shows in other
countries too you connect to japan you
get netflix japan forget about it uh
secure your online data today by
visiting expressvpn.com
h3 that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
h3 and you get an extra three months for
free that's expressvpn.com
h3
thank you thank you and finally
a big big thank you to honey what's
happening
what is that
zach
can you mute it
can they hear it yeah for sure guys
just try muting [ __ ] and see if it goes
away
okay
my laptop
[Music]
really
i wonder if it's the live stream that's
still on
the gps oh minimize yeah you think it's
just broadcasting that ipad [ __ ]
no i don't know
i mean that's a good guess but
i don't think so
i don't think i mean it sounded like oh
my god yeah it sounded like tone why are
they doing this
open it zack
that's a [ __ ] that's a [ __ ] up man
they got us good dude with that all
right you win today sky news
good call love
you cracked the code on that
yeah yeah
i knew it was tone and we have tone like
when i hit the tech difficulties button
it plays tone and so i went to the bus
and i'm like is something [ __ ] yeah
but uh i see your laptop just like
one level i'm like what the [ __ ] like
all right
johnny johnny is papa by the way when
you when you all tab to the tone for a
second the the views went up a little
bit just
should we try the tone
should we just place it down
i'll keep it low in the background all
right and thank you to honey today's
episode is sponsored by honey the
easiest way to [ __ ] save money when
you're shopping on your iphone or
computer i love honey i use it all the
time ela's the honey queen
uh she saves money so much every time
she goes pull it up dan you know what it
is i actually can't right now because i
am showing our view counter but here let
me just give you the i'll give you the
link and you can open it real quick uh
thanks to honey manually searching for
coupon codes is a thing of the past and
honey is the free shopping tool that
scours the internet for promo codes and
automatically applies the best one it
finds to your cart i mean here's one
that ela got
i think she bought a couch or something
yep
and then all of a sudden
at the checkout this drops down they
found this coupon that saved 10 that's
400 freaking dollars
that we didn't even expect or were
prepared to save and that's the power of
honey it's so easy to use it's just an
app you download and it one click
unbelievable uh
guys it's unbelievable word my call it's
unbelievable unbelievable imagine you're
shopping at one of your favorite sites
and when you check out the honey button
appears and all you have to do is click
apply coupon wait a few seconds as honey
searches for coupons you can find for
that site
if honey finds a working coupon you'll
watch the price
magically drop so uh honey doesn't just
work on desktop now it works on your
iphone too just activate it on safari
and your phone
we'll save on the go if you don't
already have honey you'll be straight up
missing out and by getting it you'll be
helping yourself and
helping the show i love it i use it uh
you can get it for free at
joinhoney.com h3 that's join honey dot
com slash h3 thank you thank you
doorbell you don't have to think about
it dude right thank you to our beautiful
sponsors
all right so the question at this point
is
um do we keep going with this gag and
watch amber turd's testimony
of which there are a lot of great
moments let's be honest maybe we can
just watch the great moments we have
thumbnailed
or do we just move on and get jimmy lee
out here i was kind of into the just
playing tone for the rest of the episode
or tone i mean we could definitely just
play maybe the tone is a little too um
too harsh but like
you know there's these youtube videos
like 12 hours of uh
brown noise
is that when you [ __ ] your pants no
that's the brown tone oh
okay what's brown noise this right here
wait why is that brown noise that's just
what it's called it's a type of like
white noise there's pink noise what's
white noise
white noise compared to brown noise
i like brown noise yeah brown noise is
relaxing i like brown noise white noise
is a lot harsher let me hear white noise
here here's 12 hours of white noise
no no no
you know i they always have um
like a light for a baby and it's like a
sound machine and it always plays white
noise which i found really annoying oh
yeah but the brown the brown noise is
where it's like distant rain i wish they
did brown noise yeah
so wait what's pink noise
uh pink noise is a little it's a little
in between it's also less harsh than
white noise let's hear some pink noise
is there any other colors of noise
there's pink noise
i don't like it
it kind of sounds like heavy rain it's
sharp
it does but
the brown one is kind of like
it's
it's got more space it's more of a vibe
yeah yeah yeah yeah i feel you with that
brown noise again pants
uh my pants brown noise
the music very gray noise it's a bang oh
you want to try gray oh yeah let's hear
gray i sleep to grey noise you sleep to
greater here's gray noise
oh that's real subtle
oh this is like the space it's kind of
terrifying it kind of sounds like
background radiation yeah it's def
right that's what the that's what black
holes sound like they have like 10 hour
space loops that are pretty relaxing so
get back to brown noise
back to brown can we should just play
that subtly in the background somebody
messaged and said green apparently
there's like all the colors green noise
you got to check out green noise kind of
curious let me just listen to some green
noise real quick brown noise so far is
definitely where it's at
sharp
yeah it's a little too tiny i mean it
sounds like heavy rain but it's just
it's not it's sharp
brown is where it's at dude
there's the brown noise brown town
oh yeah that's so nice yeah brown is
like a distant highway
oh somebody suggested whale you know
brown noise can bound with like whale
song
i bet would be like
real i'm down to try it it reminds me of
like when the ac goes on at night and
it's nice and warm
i can't get over that brown noise it's
so nice eight hours of whale sound yeah
let's get the whale sounds
and then
okay and then here i have a perfect
addition
can you turn up the whale noise i can't
really hear it
okay good oh my god this is nice
yeah wait let me listen
oh this is a bug
dude this is so relaxing and then here
let me add the perfect thing to it
and you testified yesterday that you
actually extended your contract in april
of 2020 exactly okay let's just listen
in part they extended it and helped me
and you testified yesterday that l'oreal
extended your contract again in november
of 2021 correct
it's so much it actually sounds like
really nice now it's kind of relaxing or
any of the materials uh for me
and that extension was for 20 months
right
that's correct well why don't we just
put it up and see if people are going to
watch now i heard you testified
yesterday with the brown noise and
whales torture you every day
it's kind of an interesting thing i do
um and that you look at them every day
i look at the um
online attacks the media you can't avoid
it to be honest that those statements
are often attached to
i don't look at his statements
everywhere
let's go
man we should just watch this and
pretend like nothing's happening in the
background
but you've gone out of your way to
engage with mr boldman on social media
haven't you
i have made a comment i believe once i
did not i would not characterize that as
engaging with him let's please pull up
one two wait don't crank the brown up it
was nice
[Music]
did i feel so peaceful right now i i
don't have this yet so i'm asking for
three i haven't talked before
okay okay wait yeah let me i have
another thing i want to add hold on
hold on this is your tweet right miss
herd
i'm going to move to it and publish this
tweet
[Music]
i'm sorry relevance
this is royalty free
lo-fi hip-hop mix 20-22
[Music]
this is from march 26 2021 right that's
what it looks like yes this is after he
made the statement
[Music]
did i read that right yes
yes someone said h3fm
[Music]
since your relationship with mr deb
ended
no i'm on level three
[Music]
you also have had a baby 40k we're back
up
[Music]
people be turning this on the watch and
they'd be like i don't know why but this
one's so much chiller than the other one
[Music]
chill defamation
[Music]
and you have
a major role in a movie there's
something about the whales
master team
whales are beautiful pretty trained
as i said i don't know you know olivia
said she's that's like her biggest fear
is whales
i mean they're huge and i guess
i mean i get it i know whales are like
gentle
gentle they're majestic beautiful
creatures yeah but i think it's part of
like the fear of deep sea oceans you
know
yeah which i get that fear but whales
are now
[Music]
the puffer fish right the one that turns
into a circle
no that's a that's a puffer fish yeah he
was holding me against the wall on my
neck and you know i might be the first
person to open the the first one too
uh 20 says since the brown noise my
watch says my heart rate has dropped by
five beats per minute yum
i totally believe that
let me find a different uh i had to
defend myself as best i could let me
just layer this a little more let's see
just couldn't control yourself
i tried to defend myself when i could
okay but tell me what you guys think
about this not defending myself
[Music]
it's a
eight-hour uh 432 hertz tone we're back
to the tone yeah
that gets me that card
wait is this uh a440 or eight this is
four three two oh
do you know about the whole like 440
versus 432 thing
in evidence oh
the top i don't know but the top comment
is i measured the audio and this is
indeed 432. yeah
what's so what so people think don't
tell big nick back
oh it's a devil's tone oh he thinks 432
is evil or was it 432 i forgot what the
the tone was
someone says this is the perfect sound
for taking back consciousness many years
listening to 440 right and i found this
to be god's frequency it makes me feel
exactly stronger and urgent urges
stronger against urges with the hell
i've got a lot of hate for the tone in
the chat i got to say yeah the tone is
not not good
don't leave don't leave don't leave guys
don't leave don't leave remember
we did this i know oh [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm
sorry guys i'm sorry sorry sorry sorry
the tone is out the tone is out
i'm sorry people i just read the
comments he said it was god's frequency
i'm very sorry everybody it's gone it
will never come back i was diagnosed as
delusional so i came home and went to
bed
[Music]
that diagnosis is delusional
some people say it was giving
existential dread i'm so sorry not all
the other ones
oh i have one i have one i have one okay
some rain yeah epic rain and thunder for
10 hours oh hell yeah
that's and mr death on that recording
correct that's correct you told mr death
quote i can't do that
i'm into that yeah
correct that's correct he was accusing
me of instigating something in this
situation explained yesterday
and you also told mr deb that sometimes
you get this is the weirdest podcast
we've ever done i think by far so
explained and yet the views are pretty
good these are good it's not exactly
what you told them people are here for
it yeah
you get so mad
absolutely not it's off the rails baby i
told you we were going to watch this
[ __ ] conversation with ben king
i know you guys were going to like it
we could please play i'm sorry um i
checked and i have no objection to the
entire
stop it
yo i'm fighting hard
oh i have another idea for layering
all right let's get relaxing beach
sounds
huh
can you turn up the the trial please
and you don't actually
you want to lower my epic reign
well if you want the trial higher then
that's what you have to do
how are the vibes on that new edition
um
[Music]
and you said no [ __ ] i didn't what
the [ __ ]
a little bit serious
don't they know we're vibing
bad vibes
someone said i'm over stimulated
well a shout out to the brown sound
let's bring out jimmy you know we've got
a whole great show planned
we had fun
we had fun with it would you say it was
your little experiment that you're
running was a success yeah i think so
i think if we did it like yesterday
during amber's
uh it could have gone to the moon i
think and a little bit earlier you know
yeah
but there's more there's more right love
yeah yeah yeah it's it's it's possible
that it continues to the 28th but it
might actually end as early as next week
i've heard i'm not completely sure about
so all next week they're going as well
most likely yeah but i've heard it might
end soon too it depends on how much they
have you know it's not nothing set in
stone
all right well
uh as you guys know
jimmy lee
the the the jersey outlaw
went out with zach into hollywood to do
a set
now no offense jimmy but zach did
describe it as the worst day of his life
and i think cam and
love
also
agreed that it was the worst day of
their life
i think
is that on yeah
i think uh
zach
kept thinking about tuesday
and uh
he got himself sick to his stomach and
uh the day before he
probably started thinking about how to
hang out with me and he got real sick
that's what i i got a text i'm on the
toilet i can't i can't breathe i have
peeled over on this and that i mean he
was so afraid
to go out with me this is a common
reaction with people on the street now
you know they get they get nervous zach
is there any truth that you just dodged
jimmy and that's why you
no i was legitimately sick
it was bad because he was sick because
he was he was legitimately sick of me
you're talking very quiet today
i'm just trying to do that until i start
my my thing
oh i have a whole you want me to do like
an eight-minute monologue right all
right so so here's the here's the big
name is can this oh i got it oh yeah got
it there you're a comic man man man
handle that thing hold it i want to
check audio audio
we go audio is that zach doing that
that's all that that is all zac so
basically jimmy
he has a reputation for for being overly
offensive let's say and we had a bit of
an intervention with him
uh i don't know a month or so ago after
he went out with love and zach
and cam
and we said jimmy you won the hearts of
the audience over they were taken with
the real jimmy lee right and we want we
need a
jimmy lee redemption arc so instead of
going out to hollywood
we gave you the homework assignment
to write a new
jokes
that
don't involve uh insulting random people
on the street in fact you're not even on
the street so right which is more like
reminding me of when i did the stand-up
before i started to do the youtube i did
stand up for probably four years oh wow
and had about a 20 to 30 minute act so i
was trying to reinvent that but last
yesterday this morning
i wrote a whole skit based on kind of
what's going on with me currently okay i
would say it's about an eight-minute
skit
okay so well i'm gonna since zach the uh
he's the head guy i'm gonna let him you
know count me down all right but there
are certain rules here just because
we again we don't we don't want to go
too off the rails jimmy okay
so we're giving you we're implementing a
three strike rule okay okay so if a joke
goes too far that's one strike right and
if you get three go ahead and show that
wait when i see your girl with those we
have a comically oversized cane can you
show that can you put the hook down uh
yeah okay yeah we have a comically
oversized cane that we're gonna yank you
off stage with okay
okay well i have a skit i don't know
which ones you're gonna like i hope
they're not offensive i tried to make
them not like what i do on the street
you know my street comedy is a certain
style this is different
no i get that totally our views are
dropping we got to go back to amber
what's that what your views no no no i'm
just kidding it's not your fault it's
it's just this the amber heard things
it's compelling stuff
so jimmy
um
i guess now is the time
okay so zach i'll let zach count me down
so
jimmy lee everybody redemption tour all
right there it is jimmy lee the jersey
outlaw
jimbo kimball you made it buddy did you
tell everybody i was on jimmy kimmel
i don't know if you could see but yeah
we did a whole thing for you oh there it
is okay so i i do want to tell you this
morning uh zach taking a shower
blow-drying my hair
gel in it moussing it
and then it dawned on me who looks down
there anyway
it's pubic hair you are just chilling as
pubic hair nope right no okay no good
good all right it's pretty good and did
my hotel today
and i said to the guy do you have a room
he says i have a room but not for you
so
no
so basically uh
he said you have a room but you got to
make your own bed so it gives me a key
ethan i open a door to a hammer wooden
nails i had to make my own bed
okay
[Applause]
zach and i got to tell you the people in
my hotel they're stupid ethan going to
the coffee shop the manager at a coffee
shop he looks right at me says how many
okay we'll leave it at that
okay
waitress comes over good looking young
girl ethan with one of her cohorts she
says what do you want to order i said
i'll take you over easy and her on the
side then she says do you like juice i
said of course i like jews i'm one
and the busboy comes over ethan out of
his mind off the rails kind of like your
show he says to me take out the trash i
says you're friends with the waitress
you take her out
all
right right work with me zack bingo
bingo give him a bingo the hotel gives
me a rent-a-car bingo there you go the
hotel ap gives me a rent-a-car
and they put a girl in the back and all
day when i'm driving i hear it's a hurts
it's a hurts it's a hurts
that one i don't get hurts rent a car it
hurts around a car but it
somebody's in the back working her over
a little bit right i could have been oh
there was someone having sex with her in
the baby or zach but i don't i don't
want to give names and it hurt and she's
hurt she's going it's a hurts
but wait a minute get better i'm driving
the court ethan i go right through a red
light like all you people in l.a yeah
make a right to hannah turn and a guy
plows right into me at first i thought
he was caucasian but then i found out he
was a drunk asian you see he was yeah he
gets out of the car goes right to the
karaoke bar honest to god i'm at a red
light are we treading in a little racist
territory oh no i do have my finger on
the button right now i don't know
mine is we're in we're in a bad
neighborhood okay we're gonna let the i
mean hold on hold on sorry first of all
i want to say i love i love the
storytelling how it keeps going i think
that's so fun and such a while i did it
right
and i the jokes i think that's so fun i
love it but do you are you guys wanting
you guys are going to let that one pass
so have we explained the rules properly
yeah
why are you explaining this three
strikes i'm trying to be careful but in
order to be funny i have to be a little
no it's great
be yourself jimmy
don't think about it this is just part
of the game that we're playing okay so
we go over so
so you said so the joke was
i thought it was caucasian but it was an
asian no no i thought he was caucasian
but he ended up being a drunk asian a
drunk asian and then he went to the
character then he got out of the boy
went right to the courier and what's the
joke there
well the asians they all like to go do
karaoke that's not really racial
that's not bad uh we got
the juice breaks on that one all right
wait who striked him everybody
okay
so let me let me keep because i only saw
yours okay so let's just but keep to be
yourself keep doing it so we go to a
restaurant anybody yeah the asian joke i
think some people would find that one
offensive just because you're like well
he's drunk and they like karaoke it's a
racial stereotype but okay not that i
mean we've heard worse from you for sure
we go to catch a restaurant has anybody
eaten a catch seafood restaurant over in
sure
yeah yeah ordered the shrimp ethan came
home with the crabs it's a rough night
now wait a minute it gets worse my
friend paulie went went to catch two he
ended up with chlamydia so where was the
rough night from
media chlamydia clam media chlamydia
correct
now let me tell you speaking about vd
the hookers in this town ethan yeah they
got it made they can drop it drape it
and droop it they're lucky drop it drape
it drop it draping droop what does that
mean i don't know you figure it out you
tell me
okay
all right
i mean if you don't like the jokes you
pick a topic
or i'll warm my core oh you're done
no i love the story you memorized the
whole thing that's pretty incredible
memorize all this in a day
[Applause]
oh i want to tell you about it the
recession i come out i realize it's a
recession here too i mean i'm on
hollywood boulevard yesterday hookers
are giving away toasters
i pick up a homeless girl two blocks
later i dropped her off she was home
i'm unbelievable she moved into an
abandonmentium and if you think it's bad
ab snow white just laid off three dwarfs
and a friend of mine got caught stealing
calendars at target they gave him 12
months
12 months for stealing the calendar
absolutely
and one of my doctor friends they'd be
one of my uh hold it i'm sorry i'm sorry
i got excited don't write letters don't
call in one of my doctor friends they'd
be two years in jail for having sex
with one of his patients now what's
crazy about that is ethan the guy's a
veterinarian
i mean it's a rough time that's good
talking about the wife i know you're
going to ask about the white she's mad
at me to white
because last week i brought my new asian
girlfriend home oh oh and now when i
have sex with her i gotta tell you she's
a protection a rifle i'll tell you about
that wait hold on her protection is a
rifle oh yeah she screams when i have
sex with her especially when i walk in
on her too you know yeah i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna strike you on that one
that one uh that one wasn't my
comprehension yeah i didn't totally
understand that one enough to strike oh
last night we were making love we were
trying to make love nothing was
happening wait are you moving on i
looked at her i said what's wrong can't
you think of anyone either way oh smart
strategy
i can't thank him hey hold on i told me
my chinese name last night come quick
hold on one sec oh she's afraid of the
dark i stole her naked now she's afraid
of the light
that's funny
two weeks ago
work with me okay yeah i'm trying to
work with my train authority no you're
doing good just hang on i'm tough being
funny coming off drugs work with me okay
hold on one sec jimmy
so i need to dan where'd you go
so can we analyze about the strikes that
just occurred we're we're actually
discussing it with the other judges
right now yeah so i got a judgment call
oh i had struck it because it seemed
like the input like the the joke was
that it was marital rape
rape well
because you were talking about your wife
not want to have sex with you and the
protection that she uses as a gun so it
sounds like it's a little obvious you
know
well hold on i thought that it wasn't
that i mean really not over the top that
was sort of for me it's a plain joke so
it's a clean joke for me i'm not doing
anything near what i when i she needs a
gun to hold you off
otherwise what well i want to tell you
funny hold on no no no no no no hold it
i got to tell you oh wait hold on hold
on
i protected a girl from getting attacked
last night i controlled myself
hold on kimmy
and then work with me and then ian what
was your reason for the strike
well it was a bit of a bingo
there's a bit of a runway we may have to
go back out on the street
he's going up go ahead go ahead again
it was a runaway train situation let me
tell you about my kitchen wait jimmy
chill
you know pictures does that come out i
got pictures
i know i took six i'll take more i got
you all right wait jimmy
was kidding me
my kid wants to be mentioned
wait go ahead ian i want to hear ann's
reasoning
hey ap i got more jokes tell him
no i know i wanted to do it i got your
mic today don't go ahead go ahead
hey i love you but they're they're
heckling me no i'm not i just want you
to just just give us a second i'm not
trying to fill it out zach's got me go
ahead and please
i was just saying
it was a little off the rails a little
more than we're used to so you know it
was a compilation of things i assume one
of them what was the your new you said
you had a new asian name is that one of
them right what was your new asian name
come quick come quick ab knows about
that yeah i come quick for sure
so you did you didn't like this let me
tell you something okay so that's two
strikes okay she cut me down to sex
twice a month but i'm lucky too guys she
cut out completely
so i mean i'm not doing too bad ethan
sure
i want to tell you about my kids
not that you look interested ethan but
i'll tell you anyway i
i know you don't care you're just being
polite because you're like oh i i know
you hate me zach hates me wait wait wait
is this part of the bed or part of the
bit okay i got two good looking kids
ethan and two ugly kids but i don't talk
about the ugly kids my cut my son's 21.
he says now what do you look for in a
woman i said you see your mother he said
yeah i said that's what you run from
when you see a woman
right all right but i got kids in
college i'm getting good drugs now
all right i told my oldest son about the
birds and the bees he told me about my
wife in the butcher you think it's oh
man i'm my youngest one i said you're
young you don't have it upstairs he said
dad you're old you don't have it
downstairs
i'm having a rough time with the kids
you follow me i do man follow me i'll
call the cops okay i'm sorry i won't
follow you
can i tell you about my shoot that
nobody here is interested in i'm
interested we're interested we have a
captive audience we had a great shoot
sunday we were like kirby's we were
everywhere in town and i wanted to tell
zach that our tv show is doing so good
now i'm the only one that knows about it
it's difficult for me to even get in to
see me right
yeah yeah we got some letters from the
hollywood press ethan we got two thumbs
down and the people in beverly hills
they all gave me one finger up okay nice
right and we got a beautiful letter from
the people in las vegas and they said
we're so happy that you're in hollywood
okay
so in closing a b
yeah i do want to don't point that beard
it may go off a b but in closing
what was that
what'd you say i said don't point his
beard at me it may go off
it may go okay
was that a bomb joke
because he's arab
hey you want me to go there no i don't
that wasn't for you jimmy that's for
wait wait wait wait wait wait oh that
wasn't even at the point like it looks
like a gun my mind
oh yeah
no no no you're good you're good
i will tell you this dan it's lonely at
the top when there's no one at the
bottom to be fair jimmy you have made
some racist jokes are you kidding me
compared to what i do on the street this
is the cleanest comedy
this is the cleanest
stuff you'll ever get out of the jersey
yeah that's that seems true yeah so how
was your shoot we saw some people
sending pictures of you out yeah looks
like some guy wanted to beat you up and
the [ __ ]
venice was really good because it was
packed and we went to hollywood later
and that was good and and the flea
market was funny because they threw us
out so it wasn't that i was funny but
the the process of the the little short
[ __ ] getting the police involved
and uh well he was a short guy it's
about 411 when he was one i had to put a
phone book to see him
for christ's sake and he kept making a
promise you're not on a film here and
dave's like go film so we're filming and
everybody's laughing and the cops come
over and they they ask us to leave so so
dave's like
start up and make a bunch of havoc out
of it so i'm like why do you want us to
leave what's the big deal you know we're
just kidding with people and i went to
the jackie mason thing and dave says
we're going to make the whole thing of
the flea market getting thrown out funny
so it was an accident
like me stop that stop that
wait jimmy
so the word you said
the accident is the funny part so the
word you said i'm just gonna say it so
you so because i don't think you're
gonna understand if i say it but you
said the word [ __ ] so that's
considered an offensive word these days
well what would you say a little guy
yeah little person well i could say this
if i talk about zach i'll talk about the
biggies if i talk about the uh whatever
you want to call them i'll talk about
the smallies you want to call them the
smallies was he actually a dwarf or
something or just a short no but i had a
guy a dwarf put me out of commission two
weeks ago i ran through my legs throwing
punches oh yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah this
son of a believer i had up to here with
him i'm nice
guy takes a lot of preparation h that's
why he's shrinking work with me no i'm
working this guy is a short guy
i'll tell you it's rough out there stuff
being funny coming off drugs anyway
ethan not that you know about that
because i'm not funny or because i don't
do drugs i don't know you're proof that
uh
i don't know i don't even have a joke
[Music]
i don't know what routine uh abs doing
but i wish i was doing it with him
i don't know what he's doing he looks
good yeah he's a nice guy drop the skin
care routine right you got a great head
on your shoulder right b who's it is i
don't know
dan i don't know what makes you tick i
hope it's a time bomb
and zach you're a real treasure somebody
ought to bury you
close so ethan you are one of the
world's greatest possessions
israel
i am one of the world's greatest
possessions israel
i wrote that for you compliment wait
wait it's real
israel is it like a plan where like it's
real
israel
i understand the country of israel right
because he's jewish did you know dan
your boss is jewish
i i was aware of that yeah okay can you
unpack the joke i'm trying to understand
if it's a word possessions israel it's a
compliment but you're jewish what's no i
know but if i'm not a pawn it's just a
compliment
everyone wants i'm not gonna do the lock
yourself in the bathroom joking oh is it
is it is it
can you just explain the joke like
what's the possession in the israel
thing because because i would say you're
one of the world's greatest possessions
right and the reason the punchline's
funny is number one should be short and
it should be something you don't expect
so israel who the hell would come up
with that me goofy me
okay so i guess that was a bomb it's a
it's a very like um
like dadaist joke like it's it's the
absurdity of of the punchline that okay
that's like a joke
i was thinking about the sun going down
then it dawned on me mm-hmm
that's my son by the way
what's his name theodore hello theodore
klein
he said what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
hello there
they asked me dan last week to be the
center full for reader's digest
but i don't like where they put them
staples
right right not doing it they be yeah i
wouldn't
okay don't do it
all right that's the jersey outlaw that
was good
[Applause]
how did i do am i getting the redemption
org i would
shove back to the hotel look i would say
you were right on the verge of having
three strikes
but like i would say you i think you
passed the test what do you guys think i
mean i tried to be it was so different
than on the street
ruffle on the street i tried to be
really easy absolutely it was far
cleaner than your typical routine and it
didn't really involve saying viciously i
took any insult joke out any of us you
know i didn't do any insult joke but it
sounds like you were on the street doing
your usual schtick i won't lie to you i
i did [ __ ] me yeah yeah and i planned
if zach and i were going to do this to
do this type of stuff and i had a lot of
other
you know me i wrote something like this
i said all your people in hollywood you
have smartphones
you drive smart cars you drink smart
water
but you're all sitting in traffic two
hours like dumbasses so i was coming up
with like uh
nobody nobody would be offended by that
right i was trying to come up with
generic stuff that i was going to use
with him and then he started thinking he
had to hang out with me he got he got
the gis he got sick he started throwing
up and then he felt better when he
realized the shoe was cancelled
yeah
did you did you offer to prescribe him
antibiotics or anything well i wanted to
give them some viagra and some fruit
juice jimmy of course you guys don't
know this is an actual md
dentist dmd or dmd but you can yeah so
this is the we have a really wanted to
give zach
the viagra and prune juice and he said
why would you want to give me viagra and
prune juice i said so you don't know if
you're coming or going
right sure of course that's true that's
actually a good joke that's a good joke
yeah that's good that's very good
that's cute
so how did it go on the weekend it went
really well did you get any trouble
no i counted 22 people
that recognized me and i have worked
because of you but i got to tell you the
funny story and leaving hold the phone
hold the phone okay
hold on hold
half were because of us yes and the
other half
from the street comedy which could be
really related to you because you
promote me but what what's one girl
blew me away in venice she came up and
says oh my god the one [ __ ] up dennis
i love you i can't
i have a picture of her i could probably
text it to you and she was so excited
and she said that was eight years ago
and i love that stuff you should do more
than one after dennis dude she was so
ethan
no that wasn't like i just couldn't i
couldn't get over it and and even dave
said like that girl like love you she's
like a real fan i said i only have one
at least i found one
no i'm a fan i love that one [ __ ] up
dennis yeah and so yeah people are
saying a jimmy lee versus gary collab
what do you guys think
right on the town
you know my dad gary's my dad i floated
that idea once your father is he do
comedy he thinks i mean he he thinks
he's funny he thinks he's kind of like
me man kind of like me you guys have a
symbol and there's some overlap in the
energy god i wouldn't i i would i don't
know even what that energy would be you
know what would be funny
my dad is kind of pc so like the
dropping like the asian jokes and stuff
i don't know what would be funny if you
did it in a restaurant
like don rickles did that dinner with
don where he would go with a celebrity
and they'd interview him if if we were
in a restaurant and we had a private
area it would be funny when the waiter's
coming over because i could do skits
with them and then i've seen your skits
with waiters man well no it wouldn't be
like that one
i wouldn't be like that okay that fresh
go you have like one i don't want to
does that one upset you i would never do
that again okay you could promise it
wouldn't be like that are we getting
dinner at the ivy
i did lunch at the i if you guys wanted
to do something later be my pleasure
maybe i'm here to do a dinner with gary
and jimmy just to see what happens
i i am kind of it's like
a science experiment like mixing those
two together what type of personality
does your father have is he laid back
like you jokes they just end up like
talking about like
dental you know
bike shops and [ __ ] like that
new frenemies
oh
so i have to move out here and just take
a room at the peninsula now and uh just
come over once a week and do free
enemies jimmy lee and ethan and gary
yeah gary awesome two dads and uh well
my wife and i and the family will be
here um the end of july beginning of
august for one week so
yeah stop by say hi no i mean if you're
interested in that i'll be i would i
would i'm saying let us know we can plan
it ahead of time okay so guys let's do
let's do everyone in the audience
there's 40 000 people watching by the
way thanks for having me on you guys
believe in the little guy
and uh i'm happy that you promote me you
always have a spot here on our show guys
you're nice
thank you
so let's let's how how should we rate
this in the audience like maybe a one
through five
like star rating well on the youtube
polls there's only four options so let's
do four star rating so four star ratings
one two three or four four being the
best you want me to sit there but sure
yeah you might i think it's important
can you adjust the camera please thank
you um i think it is important to
understand the the metric that we're
just waiting for
yes okay yeah pull that real close to
your so pissed away so ethan got you go
ahead uh the force the star rating are
we rating him in terms of like how he
progressed from the last time that he
was on in terms of you know cleaning up
the act and less offensive uh insult
comedy or just
did it make you laugh or not
why are we doing this right now maybe
[Laughter]
taking pictures jimmy i think um just
overall i i it's too hard to say but
just combine both of what dan said
progress
plus comedy
right you know we're gonna do a one to
four stars here so let's throw up the
pose
so let's see all right let's take now
what do you do can i ask you an honest
question because i'm older and um
i don't realize things sometimes my
youngest son he's very smart he says
that you don't realize that you're
offending people and you have a
personality disorder and you don't know
um is my cleaner comedy do you feel you
being a younger crowd is more acceptable
to people like i think my stuff if you
if you took that show on the road did
you like that better than when i'm on
the street yes yes yes but if you took
that show on the road in its current
form to a young audience i think people
j i think just being honest i think
people would probably be upset by some
of the jokes you told so even my calm
down version
yeah like i mean we're coming at it with
a lens of like we love jimmy we know
jimmy but a few of those jokes i think
would have to be so we've been the team
version of me's too much for the new
generation in a way because my real side
is the old school rickles danger field
which is way over and that's so toned
down and that still would offend some
people there's just
there's a few of them that the the
[ __ ] one sorry for saying it i just
need to say it for you
call them the smallies
the smallies the babies in the smallies
i guess what do you call them little
people little people okay
and then
um the ones about like the asian drivers
and stuff
was that bad
um
because it rhymed caucasian drunk asian
yeah just a little bit racist the
karaoke one's a little racist it's cute
though but i didn't think it was too
fresh i was trying not to get too fresh
well good news did i get a good rating
four stars is the is the uh top vote and
yeah 42 i found a way to uh it's great
to calculate the the actual like average
star rating like if it were on imdb or
something okay that's interesting and
the numbers right here just by
percentages yeah so
42 say four stars
so if your comedy special was on imdb
out of a score of four out of a score of
four we have a
three point let's just call it rounded
up and say three point one that's so
weird three point one out of five that's
not bad
definitely yeah absolutely that's great
that's a that's great do you guys feel
that that shtick was better than my
street stick oh for sure okay yeah i
just need to know so if i'm the street
i'm i try to tell you jimmy the street
stick is just out of control like you
gotta drop that whole thing
in my i'm being just honest okay that
[ __ ] is just brutal man jimmy you got to
take your glasses off you're making a
spectacle of yourself
hey you learn
zach's getting a little revenge he
learns from the best here you know
zach's stage name he i don't know if he
wanted it zach the rabbi we were gonna
put him on the rabbit hole right just to
be clear he texts that he's like this
would be a good name for you and i'm
like
he didn't want it he's lily's anka
that really stuck i know but because
he's big and he's funny and he got the
long hair like who would think he's a
rabbi that's why i thought it's funny
that is interesting i mean well i
thought it was funny i think rabbis can
look all different ways
potentially i don't you know but uh you
said your son says you have a
personality disorder is that what do you
think about that that's a pretty
wrong word and he's right and then he
said something interesting he said
people that have him don't realize that
anything's wrong with them what does he
think is your personality it's called
histrionic personality disorder history
on it is that a have you been diagnosed
with that no he he's he's smart my
oldest son so what it means is it's a
person that
needs to be in the center of the action
always has to have the attention
um here i found it it says histrionic
personality disorder hpd
is a mental health condition marked by
unstable emotions do you feel like yeah
but then i run my business normally like
you run yours so yeah i have a different
personality but when i go into jimmy lee
is very jimmy you know it says it says a
distorted self image and an overwhelming
desire to be noticed okay those second
two yeah sure
uh it says people with hpd often behave
dramatically or inappropriately to get
attention that's what i do my son said
it and and what's weird and i'll say
this to dan because he's just very
serious is i kind of know i'm doing it
but i like the attention i like to be
noticed and i want to be wow so it's
almost sad i have to do so many of these
things to do that i'm wondering why am i
doing it are you getting a fix or
something when you're out there on the
street
it's it's it it makes me feel good to
make people laugh and entertain me but
even if people are angry at you you
still like the attention yeah and that's
that's bad my wife said it's been in a
way yeah do you have uh
do you like being humiliated in a way
no i just like attention because i
didn't get as a kid it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter what kind of attention
that's what's bad and that's what my my
oldest son was saying he said you should
get attention in a good way
sounds like a smart guy my oldest son's
very very intelligent guy he told me
that many many times
do you i believe him jimmy uh do you do
you know somebody named zachary whitson
he's a guy that was right wanted to
write for me and he texted me a couple
of times he's got you guys because he he
made a donation and he said jimmy uh how
do you write some jokes he's a nice guy
there's a guy mason who i'll shout out
to who's been a huge help who's a fan of
yours found me from you who's doing a
lot of my social media and he's a kid
out of sacramento he was going to come
here but he couldn't make it but
mason i know you're watching thanks
because she's been doing all my social
media my tick tock is going up in about
a month and a half 15 thousand followers
because yeah your tick tock's popping
notice the production quality
i wanna ask you i wanna ask you a
personal question and that's okay yeah
you say
you say that as a child you weren't
getting anything get your love from the
family i left with an empty suitcase and
then look what the hell happened to me
so at what age did you leave
no i mean when you grow up you don't you
don't ever so tell me about your child
uh where were you born i'm that from
down the shore
jersey
and i had a mom and a dad and my mom had
you know mental illness so my dad took
care of mom and i had a brother and
there was no time really to take care of
us it's really sad so i'm telling you
that because you asked but
um so you know my wife said she left
home with an empty suitcase so what you
do now is you overcompensate can i just
can i ask you questions about more
questions about your childhood if that's
okay yeah i'm curious yeah you're a good
guy
so what was the what was the mental
illness that your mom was afraid she was
bipolar i see yeah so she would go
through which would she have like
psychosis and it's manic depressive so
she's up or down now i'm diagnosed as
being unipolar manicky i'm just manicka
i'm always i get up in the morning i'm
down at the coffee shop kidding with the
waiters right staff i'm i'm always up
i see so i'm unite paul i thank god i'm
not bipolar right yeah
just the but that's the reason yeah but
that's the reason that i am as i am i
don't think it it happened on purpose i
don't it's not like i do it on purpose
it's yeah no it's interesting when i can
learn why by product or how you're
brought up
so when you say
you didn't get any attention
my mom my dad took care of my mom and my
brother and i were kind of making
sandwiches when we were 10 years old
doing everything we're saying yourself
in bed you go
by yourself yeah there was there was
yeah we did everything ourselves and
maybe that's one reason i'm good with
business and successful i have to do
everything myself i was used to it my
brother too and and did your dad and mom
work
dad work mom didn't work and were there
times where you were alone at home with
your mom
sometimes mom was in a hospital oh yeah
when we were young yeah and dad was home
alone what was it like it wasn't it was
you know what's weird you want to hear
the weird story growing up you don't
even realize that yeah that you had this
kind of childhood when you get older you
realize it i don't know ethan my brother
said we were from a dysfunctional family
but we didn't know when we were young
yeah i don't know if that happened to
you but this is the byproduct i'm older
now and i want to be in the center line
really famous and like we'll do anything
and it's not good it's not bad but it's
not good it's like i'm murdering or
killing people it's just yeah i'm a big
ham that's really all it is
so were there were there times when
you're at home with your mom
yeah she was home sometimes too and what
was it like kind of interacting with her
hard to get along with her because she
was an unstable person really mm-hmm
my father was easygoing your father
brother's pretty easygoing i'm
pretty much
nothing bothers me
you think the the big problem was not
getting love for your from your mom i
think from both from both yeah
my mom was too sick to be a parent you
know talking honestly and my dad took
care of my mom
and growing up did you ever reconcile
with them at any point when you became
obviously very successful professionally
how did that affect my uh mom my mom
died when i was young and i have to tell
you no i didn't with her but with my dad
i did my dad recently died in the last
four or five years we got closer but not
my mom because i was angry
you were holding on to anger yes it's
funny we're talking serious when i've
been doing comedy yeah i held on to
anger and um
i'll tell you the weirdest story and
you'll i don't i don't know why and i
told this to my wife when my mom died it
was in 91 i didn't grieve and even go to
the grave but when my dad died a year
ago
i went to the grave twice a week for
like six months i like really grieved
for six months and and i couldn't figure
that out and i still can't isn't that
the weirdest thing
well it seems like you know
it seems like you have a lot of uh anger
to towards your mom
and i think you know maybe in retrospect
especially now that you're a father you
can kind of i try to be more from being
more effective
yeah never never try to be me i don't
have a mean bone in my body i just want
to be out there and have fun with people
and i like making people laugh and i
gotta listen to you and not maybe be so
offensive but that's just my personality
you can't change your personality well i
think it's really interesting just to
kind of learn about uh
a person why they're the way they are
exactly so maybe maybe people on the air
may understand a little more why i'm and
i and guys out there thanks for being
fans and and loving what i do or
whatever and understand maybe why i am
as i am i'm not this
axe murderer
yeah nobody thought you were actually
i'm a dentist who likes to go out on the
street and have fun and do street coming
that's really all i do and i like coming
out here because it seems the metrics
and the kpis work way better for my uh
social media uh out here this is my
third shoot
you know so it seems ethan out here um
it's uh better better than the other
locations you ever talked with your
brother about connor not close with my
brother no i didn't reconcile with my
brother really nope so what was the
conflict that drove you guys apart
well do you have siblings yes
close with them fairly
were they nice to you when you were
young yeah well my brother wasn't and
off air when we have dinner you and me
by ourselves i'll give you the list so i
me and my wife talk about that all the
time i can't let that go because of the
things ethan he did to me
my in-laws
my wife's family
loves me and they treated me like a son
better than my own brother i can't let
that go
you feel like that was when you when you
met your wife or was accepted into her
family i learned what a real family was
right and i almost cried
i almost cried and every time i'm with
him i thank him for accepting me in and
loving me yeah because i didn't get it
and lynn's mom i will say this on the
air and i know my son colby's wife lends
him on my love
and i would do anything for my wife and
her family for all they did for me and
lynn knows that i just i'm getting ready
to buy her a handbag she's going to be
on the air laughing because she wanted
something out here and she's not here
because i don't really care because
because my wife was with me from dental
school ethan
and stood by me when i had him to zero
wow good woman and your wife yeah and
your wife
you have a lot of money and i have nice
money and you got to stick with that
person that stood by you when you were
nobody not somebody that comes right now
because you're famous and you have a
fancy corner yeah because they're all
people that want you for the wrong
reason my wife worked in my dental
office in the beginning before we were
kids
yeah that's beautiful i'm glad you found
a good i'm glad i talked to you about
this because i i never thought this
podcast would even go like this hey you
never know it's the is we're off the
rails
well this one went from comedy to
tragedy to you almost it's not right
zach in a way
in a good way
when did you at what age did you leave
your home well i went to college and
dental school
so basically
what like around 18 or something no no
no i got out of dental school when i was
maybe 27. no but when did you move out
of your house oh well when when i came
home in the summers i knew jobs i was
always there there was not a real
disconnect okay there's a disconnect
with the person but i still was in there
i'm just curious when things with your
brother
well that was when we were young and i
couldn't reconcile so like when was the
when like you remember all the these
terrible things he's done so like around
what age are we talking about
young teenage years early adult and has
he ever tried to apologize or make up
for a thing he tries to but he didn't
change as a person ethan you have to be
it's got to come from here so you still
kind of see the cruelty in him i just
see well
do you know what a user is
i don't call you if i want something my
brother's the opposite i see it there it
is is he not as financially stable as
he's financially stable that doesn't
have anything to do with money it's the
person my wife always says it my wife's
financially stable it's the person it's
the character the person it's the
integrity
like you same thing with you you have a
great team of people here why because of
you same with my business it's the same
thing
right
i think so yeah yeah they wouldn't be
with you you pay them but i pay myself
but if i was some kind of a-hole they
wouldn't work for me they wouldn't work
for you yeah so that's just something
for you
if you look at the screen here this is
our uh chat there's a oh yeah love
dropping all these hearts for you this
is awesome
well thanks i never thought guys on air
i would do this and you know what i have
to say something my wife and son's gonna
say why'd you do it and you know what
guys i did it because because i felt i
think they'll be touched by it no i felt
it and again i'm the guy in the hotel
jim little at the peninsula he loves me
says you speak from your heart i go out
i picked them up two dozen donuts i went
to um sprinkles yesterday why because
they're nice
it's not hard ethan in life to be nice
and if you have a little money you share
it's even easier it's even easier yeah
i'm gonna buy my wife something i bring
them stuff they go mr lee you said one
richard mr lee you're so nice guess
guests that spend money over there they
think they gotta break their balls
they gotta kiss their ass i'm the
easiest guest there so they're nicer to
me yeah by the way you guys if you want
to come over come over have breakfast i
don't care okay sign it right to the
room it doesn't matter because you guys
are like friends now so you you you
moved out you went to college i went to
college but then when i got out of
dental school i had my own place and
started working i became so you did you
have a ton of student debt when you
finished school i had twenty thousand
dollars a student that's not that bad is
it nothing for a whole nother school
most guys when they got out and my age
had 80. now today most have 400. so wait
how come you only had 20 because you
were working 5 000 tuition each year and
my parents gave me money for room and
board oh so your parents helped you out
a little bit yeah they helped so that's
nice that they were not on the emotional
end yeah they were there financially
they were there financially yeah
and they're not bad people it's
circumstantial it's not like i'm angry
anymore it's circumstantial what did
your dad do for a living sold hearing
aids made a medium living he didn't he
wasn't rich oh hearing it's interesting
what
yeah
i grew up down to shore by atlantic city
where the casinos are that's where i'm
from right right
and so you went to law school how did
you meet your dental school or yeah i
just mean dental i met my wife in um
dental school she was in college and i
met her by accident i was on a date with
another girl and i was at a mall and
these two girls came in one was lynn and
i always liked asian girls and i said to
the girl who's the asian girl
and
she said it's a neighbor in my dorm
someone went back to her dorm and went
to douglas at rutgers i found lynn and
asked her out
and the funniest you just like the way
she looked you sought her out you're
like i went in the room
i opened the refrigerator i said you
have any egg rolls i started doing the
jokes oh my god wait a minute she's
dying laughing oh my god
you found the perfect woman found the
perfect woman to deal with me because
she found me funny she couldn't stop
laughing when i dealt with her oh my god
she went out with me that's the fluke
now how i met my wife and she stole my
egg roll a bit yeah with the egg roll on
the other and the chinese jokes and
she's still with me and still putting up
with me so
so does she she's a good egg she's a
good egg
she's good thank you guys thank you so
much do you hear that she finds you
funny still she hates me now yeah yeah
she hit your guts
yeah things have changed how many years
you've been married i've been with lynn
40 years so there you go but but where
am i where am i going and where's she
going where is where's healy going and
where are you going how long you been
together 15 years 10 years already 15
years yeah we've been married 10. right
but you've been together 15. so what do
you say she hates you are you joking
well it's like when i say to zach she
doesn't hate me i think i'm a bit too
much for people yeah but i don't think
she hates me
is she a bit over you
what do you mean by over me well she's a
little annoyed with you at times oh
definitely yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
but not in a bad way you guys have an
understanding yeah yeah we have a lovely
relationship zach howard is is i love
lynn she hates me i love hate
relationship that's a good way to say it
that's fine
well it seems like you have a pretty you
have a good son with us with a good head
on his shoulder who's giving you you
know i got two good kids yeah
how old are your kids so one's going to
be a senior and he's going to be a
dentist and the other one's just got to
villanova he's going to be a freshman
and he's going to be pre-dental they're
both going dental
well that's kind of flattering isn't it
that they're following in your footsteps
i've been telling them since they were
eight to go and they can have my company
oh
good deal for the kids easy i didn't get
did you did anybody do anything for you
to do this you did this selfie you met
me in new york with a camera your wife
filmed yeah yeah they started at the
bottom like me yeah they're walking
right into the top floor nice deal it's
a good deal yeah it's a good thing i
become a dentist can i get in on that
listen i'm in college i got to leave you
guys on the funniest i'm in college
years ago and the guy says put down your
books and that's what he says he says uh
he says if your father or father-in-law
or an abyss that makes a lot of money he
said it's not a very hard decision what
business to go into yeah that's what he
said yeah definitely you know it's not
hard decision for my kids well good good
it's nice to keep it in the family isn't
it
yeah okay thanks guys for actually
allowing me let me ask you this do you
are you in therapy to deal with all this
stuff with your family have you ever
been in therapy a little bit before but
you want to truth even yeah i'm i'm
older and i'm me it's a little too late
and you know what dan some people like
me and some people don't and it doesn't
matter what personality you have
always you're going to have winners and
losers and haters and lovers so am i
changing
at this age how am i going to change at
my age 40 49 years old
don't say anything what's the real age
what's the real age well we've been
guessing
the rabbi says no if i guess will you if
i no okay we're
why are you so insecure about your age
that's the personality thing that's what
my son said oh really so what is it if
you're afraid you're afraid to get all
got your real aids afraid of getting old
and lucille ball we said keep it 10
years younger okay so you're 40 45.
you're 75.
75. now i am how'd you come up zach i
thought he loved me how did i get hit
like that exactly i don't love you
it doesn't mean i don't love it i'm not
even close to that well i'll tell you
off here we'll talk about fear
55
no stop it getting warm getting warm
65
32
well he he was close he was close i find
it interesting that you're so protective
of that i'm protective of you do you
think people will judge you if they find
out you're really well once i get the
neck lift and everything we'll we'll
come back on here talk and everybody can
look and say yeah you know he looks
younger now how are you 45 and then
they'll buy that then have you had any
work done no no i used it
thanks no i wake up
with the neck now
i didn't mean that as an insult thanks
a.b for making fun of me when i when i
made fun of myself
so so that stuff have you ever been like
me i just wonder because it seems like
you have a lot of trauma in your past
with your like mom and dad i think i
buried a lot yeah yeah i think what
happened with me is you ever you ever
notice a person that doesn't want to see
and they just forget it try to forget
about it sure because i'm working so
hard doing my career and this that i can
i don't have time and i don't want to
dwell on it and think about it sure
because you know what it doesn't make me
feel good to do it i want to do stuff
that makes me feel yeah i mean you're
you've come far enough in life yeah
maybe it's just time to move on
that's what my business that's my
business guys because the good thing is
you know you already you've managed to
find a partnership and with a wonderful
woman you've had wonderful children
you've been very successful in business
right i mean people's emotional troubles
generally you want to treat it so that
you can achieve all the things you want
but you have right you've overcome thank
you you're like you're becoming like a
real friend yeah i mean that thank you
you've overcome a lot you've really
achieved a lot in your life most people
with what i how i was brought up would
wouldn't be able to do and i'm trying so
hard to make this a career
and i hired mason to help me on social
media and i'm doing i'm getting a few
more reels on youtube from dave from
deja vu
and i'm trying so hard with the comedy
because i want to be loved and accepted
and i i would like to get a name for
myself doing comedy so when i die
nobody's going to remember i was a
dentist and in five dental offices but
to remember you know with don rickles
and i can remember dr uh
irving schneiderman the dentist in
brooklyn right filled my tooth when i
was 11.
sure but you know you don't need to be
who cares if you're remembered in a way
i mean we all we all die i know but
isn't that weirdy that i want that see
again that i mean you're not the only
one a lot of people live their life for
glory and fit and they want to be
remembered so and like obviously it's
something that that people think about
but you know in a thousand years
nobody's gonna remember anyone that's
true ten thousand years definitely or
millions of years except for romeo and
juliet
they'll be remembered sure well you
don't you you weren't there for this for
what happened
you weren't there when romeo met julian
on the balcony i was not there he said
get off the balcony get on the pill
right he's like a romeo julia
it's a sound bite
oh that was cute
yeah um
was it hard to achieve all these things
were you kind of battling with these
demons and i think to be honest i think
to hide over it all if i worked all the
time
i never sit still i'm always working at
breakfast the guy sent me dad what are
you doing i said i got to go on a
podcast i have to write this and
memorize this in four hours he goes
you're gonna eat and do it i go i'm
gonna eat do it i'm gonna talk text my
controller and my operation manager my
business while i eat and do all three so
you think in a way constantly working i
think it may be to block yeah pain
now that you're bringing that up i never
thought of it it could be that
you're constantly moving so you never
have time to think
yeah and and i swear to god one of my
video guys said why you like this i did
you have trauma in your life and i
didn't think about because we were
shooting on sunday now we're doing this
i think that's the reason yeah it may be
to hide it
because i do have pain but i never
really projected it out and and solved
it so maybe i solve it by being funny is
there ever moments is there ever quiet
moments in your life where you kind of
just i sit like relax i'm doing it on
this trip yeah what do you think about
life and wish i was younger and um don't
don't wish i did anything different
because uh one thing i've always done in
life is what i wanted so a lot of people
get older and they're like i wish i did
this my wife and i've traveled all over
we have a beautiful family
um i've got to pursue a passion of mine
of comedy and entertainment that i love
i don't know if i'll get famous but i'm
getting to go out on the street and do
these things and camera crew and afford
to do it and make videos and enjoy it
and i can't
feel bad because i'm doing everything i
want
so um so if you could go back and change
anything would you
no no i i i would if i had gotten famous
say when i was young and was like this
big celebrity i may have wanted that
round but the problem is my mom you know
you're jewish like me and when you're
jew you're going to go be a doctor or a
lawyer and since we were eight my mom
said you're gonna be a doctor you're
gonna be a dentist so she had that's
basically what happened so she did have
some input on her yeah yeah she did so
you think you became a dentist to make
her to make her proud
jewish people do is they get that
indoctrinated in their head they have to
be a professional my friend greg rosen
he's the same way his parents his
grandfather wasn't dennis his dad was a
dentist he's a dennis brothers why did
your mom want you to be a doctor or
dentist i guess you're just saying it's
the jewish thing because my dad was a
blue-collar guy she wanted to step up
and my mom wanted yeah all her friends
were doctors when we were growing up and
do you think in a way you became a
dentist to to please her maybe it may be
in a roundabout way because it seems
like and my brother my brother also by
the way he's an anesthesiologist he's
retired oh you both became doctors why
and i'm a dentist yeah
i think so i really do
because did you have trouble kind of um
uh getting her approval
yeah you know you know what you know
what my business guy said he said um you
never got your parents approval and you
wanted it your whole life and you never
got it yeah that stuff and you still did
everything they wanted and i tried so
hard and maybe this is what he says he
says that's why you try so hard with
your staff and when you go in the street
to be loved and you try so when you
offend anybody go up and apologize like
you don't want to fight with people i'm
always trying anything so hard with
people
it could be the milkman it could be a
patient it could be
i saw a patient of mine at the diner for
lunch before i came here i bought him
lunch he's an older guy he went to
school with michael landon from a little
house on a prairie i mean i'm just
always wanting to be nice to people and
be like what did you do ab
what did i do everyone's saying aby
what did he do i said jimmy as me if i
stayed in med school
in the chat oh you're typing in the chat
oh my parents were the same way
oh so i think you you brought something
out that you made me think of something
i think i hustle and move so quick so i
can avoid pain yeah and and drama for it
so how old were you when your mom passed
away
she died in 91 so i was like 30.
and so you had had you be you've become
a dentist by then or not yeah i was a
dentist and and she was she ever
expressed like that she was ha i mean
you did what you wanted was she yeah she
was a very very jewish woman of very
very difficult people to get along with
not my dad he was easy to go my mom was
almost if you ever meet lynn and talk to
my wife she was impossible really to get
along with ethan no matter what you did
you couldn't please her
and she was a hot mess emotionally so
when you became a dentist what kind of
did she say anything about well
eventually what i did was as i
grew up and got older before she even
died i just
stepped away because i wasn't gonna go
nowhere there was no return there so
when she died there was really no
grieving process right with my dad there
was it wasn't like when she died didn't
really go to the grave and grieve for my
dad i did grieve was there a breaking
point with your mom yeah this is too
much i guess it was it was like a couple
times we'd have dinner out they would
just start up and me my wife would leave
we just had enough and my wife is just i
don't want this i love you i don't want
this and and i didn't want it and we
come to a point where that's enough
enough's enough so what kind of stuff
would she say
i can't even remember details but my dad
would drink and he would be verbal at a
restaurant or my mom oh your dad would
get it my mom would be demanding it at
dinner getting a cup of coffee they were
like just too much at the top
yeah just too much i'm almost
embarrassing like being on the street
almost yeah it almost reminds me of
going getting dinner getting breakfast
with you right right and maybe i'm
ending up i should get older with your
parents they say i don't know but the
thing is
i that that's kind of uh i had to
separate it and i i did i did separate
it so people are saying you're 61 if you
were 30 and 91.
they did the math jimmy
55. but you're older than 61.
oh so 71.
that's 10 right
keep going down okay
he's no he's 18.
people are doing the math work with me
bingo exactly work with me jimmy kimmel
a netflix original comedy special are we
getting on jimmy kimmel zach for real
rather than walking back and forth zach
can we get on kimmel on the seat rather
than going up and down the street with
the guy chasing him
i'll make it my life we're working
and so so your dad
it's was he did he have a problem
drinking
they had something it's abuse problems
but i don't the both of them yes my mom
my mom with drugs my dad with alcohol
yeah well what kind of drugs if i can
ask for for her condition
okay okay so she was was she wasn't
abusing drugs she was just or was she if
you take drugs you take drugs whether
they're prescribed or not legally and it
makes you feel better you're still
taking them
so right but if it's psychiatric drugs
it was but it really was weird drugs and
then my dad he was a boozer i see he was
a drinker so
it wasn't the most stable childhood
yeah or loving uh and then with my
wife's family you know you go up and
they actually ask you how you're doing
you're like whoa and i'm like wait a
minute these people actually care about
me it's almost like
what's going on here they're like lovely
nice people and they're just nice
and your brother became a doctor did he
did he ever tired he's older he's older
than me he's retired how much older is
he a couple years
and and so he he finished medical school
and became a doctor did you did your mom
ever express
i think she was happy we became doctors
but she was so focused on herself
because she was ill so you and your
brother had no neglect do you think oh
yeah well we grew up in the same house
yeah yeah not that we're close but we
did grow up the same way yeah so ethan
would gary adopt me
my dad
i think i think you guys are more like
brothers we're more like brothers
you might be able to adopt him oh i'm
kidding
what's your mom's name
donna donna okay yeah okay um
it's a shame you've been estranged from
your brother though because you guys
have such a
you know
it could have been similar could have
been different and when i have dinner
with you i'm going to tell you the story
but i don't want to do it on air it's
personal but there's a reason why you
ever give people million chances and
they keep messing up sure that's
basically and i would tell you that
detail off there you just kind of oh no
there's chances and chances and changes
i see i see and i'm like columbo i watch
everything he does and he thinks i'm a
dummy because i don't say nothing you
know colombo acts stupid but he knows
what's going on the detective and he
keeps failing all the tests after a
while i mean my wife we put the fork in
them
so
so
he has two grown kids he lives in san
francisco he's got a nice friend he's a
nice wife and a shame danny and mike
they're nice kids
well but you know what you know what my
business always says because we talk
about staffing we talk about people it's
the person
and i think in life you're a good person
or you're not there's good people and
bad people
you know we you're good guy you felt bad
that zach got sick you invited me on
here if you were a guy that was a not
give a [ __ ] nice guy i'd be stranded i'd
be with a a hook in newark with carmen
magnanzo
you know what i mean so you have a good
heart you felt bad and i'm like that
with people too i have a big heart and
my wife and i would do anything for
people we're like that we're really good
people deep down and my wife does
amazing things for people oh yeah she
had a teacher
in in my son's class who
he got burned out of his house his name
was mr goldberg she gave him like money
to get a new place
who does that right you should have seen
the letter
that this guy wrote my wife it was like
a 10 page letter
i said lin you're like unbelievable my
wife
you're going to meet my wife one day i'd
like to
i got to meet the lady who settled down
with the outlaw yeah she she's probably
the nicest person you ever meet i love
lynn she knows as much as i care with
her and the stuff she's done for people
and the kindness that she does and the
things that she does that's why i know
my brother's not right because i see how
nice people can really be right
well
you're going to get all you're going to
see the same thing with people and as
you get older you'll be closer with
people that are good to you and love you
yeah
well it's interesting to see you know
you guys got brains i mean
two doctors a dentist we are you got a
couple i don't act like that on the
street no i act like i i gotta tell you
i wouldn't expect it you know in a way
see portrayal on the streets like rodney
dangerous wise guy
yeah but i i'm a really uh a sensitive
kind person that's smart and that whole
thing is a whole stick yeah yeah that's
a whole character like like any
character rickles wasn't really like
that he was a sweetheart
it's just an act sure yeah
well
i think that that was
thank you for sharing all that i think
it was very interesting do you think
that the way this turned was good or bad
for your fans and us the terms that it
went for people love to see the uh the
real person yeah absolutely i was gonna
say i didn't know if it's a what do you
think zach you think it was a good thing
that we swung it this way jimmy i think
people are seeing a side of you they
never saw we needed to see oh so maybe
this is a really good thing because wow
like the outlaw is like the tip of the
iceberg and i think it's a fascinating
to understand what's going on underneath
hmm you're a sweetheart people are
loving it lots of love for jimmy and
jimmy can i say something you're worried
about people remembering you i think a
lot of people remember especially those
close to you is that you are someone who
continued to pursue your dream
even though it's later in life you have
been successful you're still chucking
towards your dream and that's very
commendable i feel like you look pretty
good
you look pretty good for 80 my friend
seventy
seventy nine who said that zach
exactly i'm calling i'm calling rabbi
kimowitz
you know when we're done he did my
circumcision jimmy
did you think this would uh be a
redemption like this or do you think you
know this is a full redemption
redemption we were doing this and we're
going to talk like about my shoot sunday
i didn't have no idea this all right it
got it got way too good for you so i
don't know i thought it's nice as long
as no it's it's too nice so what i
wanted to throw it back to you tell us
your most racist joke now
yeah
tell us your most offensive joke
something about it we gotta swing it
back because it's just people like you
too much now okay so you want a racial
joke no slurs yeah just no no like
racial slurs
like the n-word or anything here's a
racial joke but it's not a bad one um if
i go on the street there's a black guy
i'll say uh you need the jews because
the black's got the rhythm but the jews
own the instruments
okay so that's pretty bad it's basically
basically like i think that's pretty
good you know you would say the black's
got the rhythm but the jews owned the
club the nightclubs so back in the day
the jews owned everything yeah
yes yeah no i guess it's an old style
joke so now yeah it's definitely old
style yeah
um i'll give you the arab pass if you
want to make any arab jokes
the arab jokes um
uh if i see a person on the street and
they they say they're arab i say i'm a
jew don't don't hurt my family i do like
one of them oh you telling me yeah i say
i'm a jew just don't hurt my family i'll
give you my money my passport whatever
you want just don't hurt me yeah but
i'll tell you the funny arm joke i said
i said god
looked at the jewish people the arab
people and he said so the arabs
get to keep the oil
and the jews get to cut off the tips of
their
well the arabs actually also do that no
but it's funny because it's an old style
there but it's
zach
zach was a good guy no but arabs also do
circumcisions
oh okay right and then yeah the other
joke was the one that what was it i had
so much gay as i thought i was being
followed by arabs yeah that one that was
bad there's also the osama bin drinking
one
that's the ones acted so
do you have any other ones that maybe we
could retire now about like any kind of
minority or do you have any uh jokes
about white people
well i did i did a thing with with mason
it was hysterical
so uh it's a picture of me with an asian
girl in the street it says bring him
asian
never caucasian meaning like we have an
amazing girl not in america but it hit
like on instagram and it was funny so
there was a clip where some guy i
prompted on the street in march and i
said like if you're not gay you're on a
waitlist he goes bring him asian never
caucasian he said it not me so he would
say in my tagline and it hit it hit
pretty big on tick-tock tick-tock we
have his memes in the dock
oh yeah let's see we have some jimmy lee
stuff oh yeah guys i wanted to show
everybody what jimmy's been up to on
instagram maybe you guys can go follow
him there i don't know where you are
with noah beck how did what the hell is
this that's a picture at boa about two
months ago my name is i didn't my son
said dad that's noah beck i'm like who
the frick is noah beck he says he's a
famous tick tock or i go on he's got 36
million followers i said let's go blake
he goes what are we doing i said we're
going over to meet him and get a picture
my son's like you can't do that you can
do that which one's like the older one
or the other the older one blake got so
embarrassed so blake i said blake here's
what we're doing we're going over you're
taking a picture with my camera of me
and i'm going to do you he goes okay so
we go over and i said hey noah uh jimmy
lee the jersey outlaw i'm a street comic
and we're in town could we get a picture
because sure the guy couldn't have been
nicer yeah he's he seems like a nice guy
and can i tell you something weird about
him you even got him to do the jazz
hands yeah did you did you i told him
yeah can i ask you a question what did
you do to your face face turned it my
son said stop phase two you've face
tuned the hell out of that i mean it's
an airbrush to god
my son's like stop face tuning jimmy we
love you but you're starting to look
like a wax figure in my guy okay i'll
stop better stop face tuning so but this
is a this is a direct post on your
instagram who did this this amazing so
that's what mason does mason does all my
great who's mason he's working
on social media he's very nice guys
gone wild what do you mean gone wise we
just took a picture we had to come up
with a tag gone wild you know what i did
forgot to tell him to do i wanted him to
i wanted to roast him and i thought
about it after that night i said blake
if i had asked him if i could roast him
and he filmed it and i went on just do
it now
noah beck if you're listening
get ahold of jimmy lee the jersey outlaw
at the peninsula hotel for a couple more
days
and have dinner with me and ethan and
the group and let's roast us
let's get you right on to the tick tock
wait if you have a roast for him
you can do it now you might see it
so if you're watching noah beck me and
ethan we want to know what job you're
doing when we figure out what job you're
doing we're going to let you know
all right it's kind of just the classics
it's the classics yeah ethan told me had
a lot to do with your career he tried to
stop it
okay it's it's basic yeah yeah because i
don't know too much about him but if i
met him and he breakfast me on his
history of himself okay i would be able
to do a better roast you want to explain
this post this again this is a post
wife the jersey alice on the street
what's with the tiny uh that's uh mason
he's on some heavy duty drugs
yeah and he put ouijas in and all that
so i don't know why he did it maybe
because he's very emotional he's very
talented uh emojis emojis uh the
multimedia stuff yeah it looks like it
looks like whatever you're paying him
double it double it well i give him
about 250 to every two months
okay then double it okay mason you heard
that
yeah so he you guys are good you guys
are good what he does is he'll put the
tick tocks up and down and he'll put
words in and they get a lot more no
that's good your tick tock's popping
yeah so again i'm just trying to say
you know with the face tune it's a lot
it's a lot you're killing me i'm just
being honest well i'm just being honest
because it's when you look at it you're
like this man is faced it's just it's
kind of does it looks like two-faced
ridiculous looks like you've got it done
by the mortician
oh jesus christ i love you
zach is out hey b he's out for blood
today he's still upset about the last
time jimmy you look great i mean
not even just for your age you're a good
looking man for 75 you look great
you're a handsome stud you don't need
that you're not you're too you're too
you worry too much about your vanity
your look um
like zach yeah
exactly the same way though no
i i said you're right
you're right you just you you're raw
dude you gotta raw dog it and just go
out here let's see this is another post
oh go on to tick tock well hold on these
i love okay jimmy likes to rock but the
jersey outlaw loves to roll like rock
everyone did you write that i wrote it i
gave them the pictures no good or good
like it or is it not current um
it's not i mean not good are those the
bandito girls they are the bandito girls
yeah a lot of face tune i'm just saying
i mean you can even see
it looks like the glasses were like
yeah those laces are one they're
actually on you yeah
okay
lock the doors
that's great all the cops that's greg my
buddy the dentist from back home so we
we had a limo drive us around so
lock the doors and call the cops like
i'm on the loose and then what's wrong
with the 100 in the flying money that
you have to ask uh why is there amazing
walking here
mason mason's got some i said he's on
heavy duty drugs there's someone with a
walker here i know okay i don't know
what major mason what are you doing on
these uh things do you know what this
emoji is what's that mason oh i'm asking
you mason text on the thing what you're
doing okay
and there we go the craziest sonnet sons
[ __ ] the biggest son's [ __ ] alive
crazy sons of [ __ ] live no it says the
craziest sons son's a [ __ ] yeah like
you're italian like you're uneducated we
did that on purpose no the craziest
son's a [ __ ]
a son's a [ __ ] son's a [ __ ] okay son's
[ __ ] right alive uh that's that's the
one i want you to do bring him asian
never caucasian i wouldn't post that
that's bring him asian never caucasian
but be sure to bring him yeah but that's
wild and also to show who is this just
some random girl
zack's ex that's a lot
you know who that is
yeah yeah you can say it that's a girl
zach dated very very dumb amazing her
name's one dumb [ __ ]
that's mad you got it you you said i
could fight me
that was the worst i had to throw one in
it wasn't the curse that was bad
right what it wasn't the [ __ ] oh what
was there
it was the racial accommodation well i
know you said i could curse so no it
wasn't cursed that was bad oh the racial
connotation some dumb what did you say
one dumb [ __ ] yeah that's racist
you said you want a racist joke no i
know i'm just we're trying to help you i
know i know but yeah and then the bring
them asian never caucasian is a lot and
it's heavy
isn't the full line jimmy correct me if
i'm wrong bring him bring them young
well the whole full line is bring them
bring them but bring them young but not
the university bring them young but
bring them in stilettos but be sure to
bring them but bring them asian never
caulking bring them young what kind of
age are we talking about
we did this when we were in our 20s me
and king james we would go to clubs we
say bring them young bring them in
stilettos but just bring them what age
are we doing our 20s okay that's that's
about 20 years ago okay aren't you in
your 20s now no how about 20 years yeah
no i got you yeah uh real quick jimmy
your phone is going off you're getting a
lot of instagram support oh people are
following you on instagram oh
wonderful could we go and take they're
gonna give me kimmel oh wow you actually
made it jimmy i did this one yeah
does that what does that do for you does
it make you feel good to see that it
looks real that would be great if i got
a call and the guy said we know you're
working hard doing street company would
you guys come up and and stop up
i would die
who cares about jimmy kimmel you're on
the issue podcast
oh i know i love being on this but could
you imagine getting one late night yeah
could you picture that oh
dropped liver jimmy you're not chopped
liver you i love you stop that don't
ever say that dream i love you but you
got to talking to mike
sorry i could so [ __ ] sorry
can you show the tick tocks because i
have a good time well hold on hang on
bruno mars meets jimmy lee
oh yeah what about bruno morris
[Laughter]
yeah what's this
stop i'm with av on this one
bizarro and off the rails it's jimmy lee
i thought that was good you don't like
that face and everything oh it's the
face that's funny well it's like you're
you look crazy so i wrote bizarro off
the i got the off the rails idea from
you yeah that one's good i meant to hit
mute not okay crazy sons [ __ ]
[Laughter]
well with us we got i mean we've we've
looked at your tick tock i just want to
tell the fans to tick tock any any
support on the tick tock it's at the
jersey outlaw that's our driver and
branding tool and we would appreciate
any love and followers on that linkedin
the uh
description
jimmy how are your cameo numbers
they were really good after you oh yeah
and then two weeks after nothing do i
get five percent take ten percent i'm
not doing it for the five is the number
yeah
i made then i owe you i made
about five five or six hundred dollars
that's five percent
no that's what i made i didn't make it i
did about 10 of them all right well
there's 12 of them listen no offense but
we since we have the cane
i want no no do it if you do it around
his body oh we're am i getting shrifted
off yeah we're going to we're going to
no
joe's about to end oh it shows any can i
just walk off on my own no no no no no
you have to do this this is important we
got the cane
all right all right
all right actually you want to try this
jimmy come sit i i had a funny idea okay
come see it and then yeah try so we're
going to use the cane to drag you
because your chair has wheels oh you
want to do the whole thing yeah so so
bye jimmy
[Music]
all right you're out of breath well
jimmy lee the jersey outlaw is there any
actually is there anything you want to
say as we as we end the show
yeah go ahead
forget about all the the mishigosh uh
it's hard when you're in entertainment
doesn't matter what type of
entertainment you do to have a friend
wait a minute
son's a [ __ ] what are you doing over
there
jesus christ yeah the arab picking on
the jew
the honorable people don't do zach call
the rabbi
no i want to talk very seriously it's
hard in entertainment to have a friend
and somebody that is in your corner and
you've always been in my corner always
and i appreciate it and i love you and
zach as much as we can have fun
i appreciate the love and of course
and i just i just want to say that now
wheel me off love you jimmy i love you
and guys wait come on i'm here one next
day come if you just want to have lunch
or something tomorrow okay
all right all right
[Applause]
thank you wow what a nice time what a
powerful episode uh jimmy
jimmy lee
powerful appearance we learned a lot
laughter tears
we saw we learned a lot about johnny
depp it's been a whole experience
honestly
hey
jim jimmy's just talking at full volume
trying to chat everyone up we are still
live jimmy give us a sec okay
great guy
um how long we've been going i think uh
he is jewish by the way people are
saying jimmy's not jewish he is jewish
yeah so we'll just wrap it up here hold
on uh
what a show huh folks nobody does it
like they street podcast that's right
oh and shout out to everyone who gifted
subs that was freaking awesome man yeah
that is really cool shout out to youtube
such a cool feature
[Applause]
that's um awesome guys
a lot of people saying they had a lot of
fun today yeah it was a good app it was
fun
stay off the reddit though
why
that bad what happened on reddit well
you'll see wait seriously what happened
now i gotta check well i think all the
people that were not vibing with the uh
social experiment here today uh
converged there whereas all the people
that were vibing with it stayed and were
in the chat and so you know there's sort
of a natural
separation but are they just mad about
it are they actually like mad
uh
i don't know about matt as much as like
a lot of like this is the worst episode
they've ever done okay that's fair um i
don't mind that this is literally
unwatchable yeah it was i mean listen it
was experimental
for sure i thought it was avant-garde
some people see it as
some people say unwatchable i say
avant-garde i say the bleeding edge of
comedy right yeah sometimes you gotta
take risks we variate here it's fun we
switch it up you're not gonna get the
same thing every four episodes a week i
mean come on i thought it was hilarious
you want the same thing every every
episode you know i had a lot of fun
doing it and to all the haters those
views weren't kept going up
okay yeah
yeah i don't
i don't see haters i'll say detractors i
would have stopped if our views weren't
going up but they kept going up i i i
was caught off guard by it to be you
know
frankly i was trying to make it as
unwatchable as possible
and the views kept going up there are
some funny posts on there as well uh
there was one that really cracked me up
here let me pull it up real quick
uh that was pretty funny too
don't panic i'm not a crazy person
somebody uh
did the crazy person pick-up artist ever
reach out by the way
they're watching the stream oh that was
the one i was looking great commentary
on the gym oh it's a penalty
yeah exactly great commentary thank you
somebody appreciates uh
somebody appreciates the work we're
doing here
gifted uh
mega did you just buy more gift subs
wait how much another ten you gotta you
gotta wait that's mega awesome nerd yeah
and he did twenty earlier oh that was
you i gotta compensate him for that
that's what i'm saying i'm just gonna
end up we pay you dude
the other way around we gotta we go i'm
gonna have to pay you for those gifted
subs
but thank you that is nice for uh the
community members
oh nathan asked uh dad is in the chat he
said when does the trial end
oh we forgot to announce the verdict
oh uh well that you'll have to tune in
we probably got postponed
postponed because the trials
is there more trial this week love
uh yes maybe i don't know okay excellent
a lot of people are saying that the
closing arguments are gonna be really
good
really juicy because they're gonna bring
everything together you gotta tell you
gotta tell me when that is so i can
actually be on time i'll show up for
that [ __ ] bro i want that hundred
thousand views well you know it starts
at like
seven in the morning east coast time or
something
[Laughter]
i can be here at ten
okay
because that's i mean that's like
probably like halfway through the day
for them ethan i didn't quite catch your
spit take could you do it one more time
oh
oh
that was classic
play it again yeah it's on you you know
it starts at like 7 a.m on on the east
coast
uh the time time was the first time was
way better way better it was one thing
sorry sorry i mean you can usually get
it come on you usually get the shot one
more time for tick-tock one more time
one more time i need a good clip okay
okay okay get some liquid in the in the
guy be on standby perfect ethan you know
the trial it starts at like 7 a.m east
coast time right
nice and you could just kind of edit
that into the initial nice that was
great yeah i got it
[Music]
oh it starts at nine somebody corrected
me yeah i was i wasn't sure 27 i just
knew it was j money said the 27th what
is today the 18th that will be their
last possible day it could be i i think
we'll be on top of that guys
you have any other funnier posts from
the subreddit i mean that was funny
enjoyed that um
let's see
there was another one of somebody
staring at the tiny [ __ ] little bomb
that was great i gotta say man there are
some good goofs in there i don't know
what all y'all here's one detractors
my boyfriend watching off the rails
today
[Laughter]
that's awesome dude
that's so funny come on now
uh i love the family you guys are the
best fans in the world i gotta say it's
so nice
we have such a great family here don't
we another five gifts gabe by the way
thank you gabe really really do i wish
you guys could have heard that stadium
how many people screaming family like
it's insane oh was it really yeah i
couldn't hear crazy yeah
i think that's why i was so calm
otherwise i would have had a panic
attack but family family family family
family family family stop stop
um
oh yeah xqc gambling thing he's back
we'll talk about that on
tomorrow i guess maybe it's a good
leftovers thing because hassan well his
son is very familiar and he was with
yeah maybe we should talk about it with
the song tomorrow yeah it doesn't quite
fit the usual leftovers thing but it is
something you and i or you could cross
over
yeah exactly
well guys we'll see you tomorrow morning
at 10. well see i show up at 10 on
thursdays i can show up for 10 for
johnny depp you were like a half hour
lately last week okay but most of the
times i'm on time okay hopefully
tomorrow you'll be on time
usually you're on time i will
yeah that might slow you down
how are your bowels today my bowels are
great what are you having for dinner
tonight
i've been eating clean i have this meal
uh delivery service that just it's for
like weight loss but the food is really
good it's just like lean protein and
vegetables right i've been i've been
trying my best to stick to that not
snacking
uh so you know when i don't eat gnarly
my bowel movements are
are immaculate yeah
well yeah stay away from the pizza
tonight and we should be in good shape
for the morning
yeah jimmy is just jimmy is well she's
chatting up cam you know so jimmy was
asking me some questions as i was
walking him out and i grabbed cam and i
go this camera he'll take care of you
and cameron looked at me in the eye like
i betrayed the [ __ ] out of him sorry cam
how's it going out there you good
he's good he's busy they're they're good
kim's a good guy yeah he gave me a
thumbs up they're having fun
so we'll see you guys tomorrow at 10 a.m
for leftovers it's actually gonna be it
sounds like a fun app talk about the xqc
thing and there's so much there's so
much there's so much conservatives have
lost their mind on twitter it's nuts i
mean these people are
insane yeah we're gonna have to do like
a mega segment on uh on elon alone just
his shenanigans in the last week have
been completely off the rails oh and
then there's the quartering who said
that he wants his dad to finger his
bottle but we were going to talk about
that today because it felt a little more
specific to the show but no that's a
leftovers thing now okay well we'll talk
about philly d stuff to happen to black
people
oh that's a good sound
also people saying uh when is olivia
coming back next week oh my goodness
i cannot wait for that olivia helps me
so much yeah olivia has a big help on
that she's so prepared that's so nice
man that's gonna be good to have her
back
we need those ladies
oh yeah jordan peterson lost his mind
did that this is one of the crazy pool
going crazy on twitter
but jordan the jordan peterson tweet was
one of the craziest things i i've seen
this man is a therapist and he's like
this woman is fat and disgusting and no
author authoritarian is going to trick
me of that
uh
there was like a
i was like dude you're a therapist
you're literally a therapist like what
the [ __ ] are you saying
yikes
anyway we'll talk about it tomorrow good
[ __ ]
all right guys love y'all
family family
[Music]
wait hold on before we
before we go
keep that music going please
what are waiting for
[Music]
i got a piece so bad i can't bomb
oh
is that the whale sound
[Music]
okay can we get some brown
[Music]
and then rain
[Music]
beach sounds
[Music]
oh and then and then wait hang on
let me
wait hold on
this is the missing link
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys thanks for watching we'll
see you tomorrow morning
is to get into what the definition of
those words mean to him
never i never even addressed it
[Music]
[Music]